honest to God I'm not saying I would say
it but I probably could say
if I was on stage you know
good enough I think I was
[Music]
perfect
what's up guys I am Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast I am
here with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys guys what's up we're getting
straight into it all right uh the nice
guy clock is probably non-existent today
we're just going to get right into it
fan favorite the most I think you're
here the most out of anybody's ever been
here you guys ask every five seconds
this is the next Goblin episode what's
up dude thanks for having me back thank
you a different new spot different very
different very different I'm so used to
like smoking a joint spending 30 minutes
chilling before but I know this time wow
we're really like we're here Marty at
the table now this is crazy so much
better yeah I know we can it's like a we
can have a conversation without Marty
screaming from the corner getting some
Echo right or having a look around I'm
having to take the headphones off what
was that hope the cameras are running
cameras yeah it's dope dude
this is I think your fourth either
fourth or fifth we've done we've done a
lot you're officially we've said you're
official are Joey Diaz you're officially
the guy that can come back forever and
we're always going to have fun and no
one's gonna go again
no it's just a good it's just fine I
mean we have like absolutely nothing
that you know is really planned for our
episodes it just kind of happens you
know except the first thing yeah because
that's when we first met yes yes and
then every episode after that just kind
of devolved into like a sesh you know
which I think is the best best way to do
it you know truly thanks for having me
back thanks for brightening up the
studio yeah you guys look like you came
from a funeral and I'm out here looking
like I came from I look like it came
from uh
I didn't hear what you said to the end
you the colors are great I look like I'm
hanging out with OG today yeah like I
chilled and went to the store I actually
got this shirt from his store go to
cholo land he told me and it wasn't
called cholo land it was a store I was
wondering
I told you I bought this for children to
be a firestore theme though bro you
should get like a little side hustle.com
you saw everything the highest tell him
to get on that before this episode drops
so someone doesn't take that actually
I'll take it from GoDaddy before this
episode drops let's give it to OG
because that's actually smart perfect
cost eight dollars yeah cholo land dude
I have so many little domains just
parked up I have like probably like 20
websites just parked if I ever wanted to
because you just well I have a bunch of
like variants of only gas uh oh yeah
yeah I have um I was gonna do a hot toss
line at one point but that fell through
because the sauce is sucked so I uh I
have like gobsauce.com oh and like stuff
like that so yeah dude I love just
copping random domains it's fun there's
a lot of people that did that on
Instagram they're early Instagram people
throw names and sold them so back when I
was younger that's one of the things
that I used to do to make money I used
to like buy OG like usernames and flip
them my old Snapchat name was just the
word become and I sold that to some kid
for like I think like 300 400 bucks but
I used to like flip OG names when I was
younger what how do you stumble upon
just becoming CBD well so I never I
never like created the accounts myself
they were always like Bots would get on
that on new apps super quick
um I remember there was like a couple
smaller like Niche apps back in the day
that I tried to get OG names on like um
there was one called bite there was one
called photo
um you remember photo no it was photo
but like three H's and you would take
these little like gifts it was a series
of photos and then like it would create
a gif out of it almost like a little
Montage it was a cool app but I like
farmed a bunch of OG's on that never
worth any money because the app sucked
um but I used to like buy just random
usernames that were worth like 50 bucks
you know 60 bucks and like sell them to
kids but I never made like that much
money off it it was something that like
you know I would just do every now and
then in the weed world it's so it's such
a real thing I know somebody that sold
CBD for like 40K yeah oh I bet dude the
guy who has my twitch name right now
wants 10 bands for it 10 mil yeah it was
eight and then it's like yeah yeah so it
was eight so I hit him up again to like
renegotiate I was like I'll let it
settle on him you know because he wanted
me to pay all cash up front I'm like no
shot like whatever
um but also he's like one of those real
like old heads who like he's not a
stoner he's not even really like an
internet guy like he just took them he
just has the name and he's some guy who
streams like Dungeons and Dragons you
know like well we talked about this
that's right yeah just some guy who
streams just some random like Dungeons
and Dragons or Warhammer or something
like that and uh he I just don't think
he cares about the money you know like
he's like nah bro I'd rather have the
name I'm gobbling so I'm just you know
as terrible as it is to say I'm waiting
for him to croak you know like I'm
waiting for him to do his thing in 32
years
my 50th birthday gift is Twitch TV slash
Goblin
[Music]
what's up guys pausing this episode to
give you guys some breaking news
manscape is now selling beard products
that's right guys they've gone from the
waist to the face to help you get rid of
your bulky trimmers so brand new for
manscape is the beard hedger Pro kit
keep yourself groomed keep yourself
looking good turn some heads with the
new beard Pro kit they've now created
the best tools like I said from the
waist to the face for you to make sure
that you look good you're groomed at all
times so right now take advantage of our
deal guys that's manscape.com use our
code y-o-l-a that's Yola 20 off plus
free shipping this beard has your pro
Kit's about to change your life it's a
waterproof cordless trimmer with a
rotary wheel that gives you 20 different
lengths and one so no more messy drawers
full of accessories and add-ons for your
clippers plus the trimmer comes with a
titanium coated t-blade that is smooth
on your face and tough on hair
satisfaction comes one stroke at a time
the pro kit also comes with four
dermatologists tested formulations for
post trim care now listen up guys all
your hair is different believe it or not
so manscapes coming with the beard
shampoo and conditioner specially
designed to moisturize read produce
ingrown hairs and replenish your natural
oils to keep that beard looking fresh
manscapes remember about the post trim
care I was talking about manscape also
offers beard oil to keep you from going
dry after you shaven as if it couldn't
get any better manscape's coming with
the beard bomb it's moisturizing and
shaping that beard using fresh
eucalyptus Rosemary and lavender
essential oils but yeah guys it does get
better the beer Pro kit also comes with
three free gifts beard brush a comb and
scissors to make sure you're looking
like hook at the end of this you want to
look tidy you want to look like hook
want to look like Justin Boyd you you 20
off of codiola manscape.com
20 off manscape.com Yola remember that's
20 off when you go to manscape and use
our code at checkout that's code Yola 20
off plus free shipping it does not get
better than that the manscape beard
hedger Pro kit is the Premier solution
to face grooming have a dope ass day
[Music]
um well it's not like officially in the
policy but yeah if an account's inactive
for a long time you're dead generally
you can hit them up and be like hey
here's who I am you know I would like to
have this name it's inactive and Twitter
especially will do that Twitter will
free it up
um YouTube If you have an at you want I
think sometimes we'll do it if like a
random you know no post account has it
uh but it depends on the platform but
you could try it you know it does work
sometimes but I don't think it's like
written in the policy anywhere like yeah
if this dude's dead you just join this
thing right did you imagine if you
murder this man I mean it's yours that
would be crazy dude people with OG names
would actually be getting smoked like
that sounds like horrible that sounds
like some Black Mirror yo I would um
imagine you just had Yola like just Yola
is your Instagram and you're like up in
the comments you know some guy like uh
let's say you're talking [__] with some
guy he can't even insult you like your
name is Yola on Instagram you know it's
like you already won the argument yeah
you don't even have to respond anymore
you know
I like the way you broke that down but I
don't shoot somebody for my name no yeah
like like well because once you get the
name I'll just add that underscore
yeah but like I don't know
something that hits different about that
OG name oh I get it even still today
when I see someone with like an OG
username in my comments I'm like damn
you know like I go check out the profile
like how'd you get that you know how do
you feel about we talked about this a
little bit last episode but how you're
gonna be able to like sign up for like
premium Instagram now and get all those
badge and all that stuff so I on one
side of me I'm pissed off about it and I
don't like it because I feel like
there's a lot of people that should be
verified that shouldn't have to pay for
it that should be able to get those
features right yes yes 100 I'm kicked
off um
but also on the other hand I'm glad that
they're finally offering some sort of
solution because it was obvious that
they were never gonna fix the
verifications yeah them on Instagram
it's like they they were never gonna
change their mind about weed influencers
or anything like that if you are not
like a mega celebrity on Instagram with
at least five mil they don't care about
you you know at all so um
on one hand I'm glad it's there and I
will be buying it for sure uh I have it
on Twitter and it's great you know like
it but it's also like dude it's like pay
to win social media you know like
literally on Twitter I've noticed since
I bought the blue verification my tweets
have been doing like way better dudes
people go oh it must be oh yes I have
broken so prior to buying my check mark
my record for like most likes on a tweet
was like two and a half thousand three
thousand or something like that uh I've
never had any like viral tweets or
anything you know but after I bought my
check mark I've gotten like six tweets
with more than that like not even trying
to get like you know bangers because
people will stop and go what's this blue
Check Yes it catches your attention but
I'm also worried that it's gonna devalue
the checkbook a lot because
I feel like it should be a paid feature
but also like how do you separate a
check mark from someone who actually is
a celebrity or you know an actor someone
who is a professional and should be
verified from just like the average dude
you know sure I think the like eight
different colors of check marks they got
on Twitter are stupid they make no sense
is that an action right now or is that
just still like the color thing yeah so
companies and like brands have a yellow
check mark and then if you buy one you
have a blue and then politicians have
like gray but there's there's more than
is that what it meant yes the gray is
like a politician or official or
something like government official
um yeah I don't I don't know I mean I
personally
I think it's it's kind of stupid but
it's better than not having anything so
yeah there should be like a cut and dry
solution to it especially with Instagram
yes Instagram needs it otherwise you
just got like scammers out there just
kind of like claiming the telegram
scammers can buy check marks we were
just talking about this the telegram
plugs like dude I had a fake Hash House
account follow me the other day I sent
that over to John I had a bunch of like
I've had so many fake accounts of people
I follow like hitting me up recently and
imagine if those guys got check marks
they're gonna wreak havoc dude because
like people don't understand like people
like don't get that if someone what I
always tell to people like what I always
say to my viewers is if someone is
openly advertising that they will ship
you something they're not good they're
not gonna every Real Page every real
even people who will actually ship you
something they're always going to have
nothing for sale or like don't contact
me about sales or anything like that
they will never promote it they will
never advertise it but a lot of people
don't understand that you know a lot of
others yes yes it's the same guy buying
the Gucci bag on the thing like eighteen
bucks this bag
it's real right what is the same thing
dude some people are just stupid that's
really what it comes down to I'm sorry
but I just posted when's the first time
you heard of my content and somebody DM
me first time I ever heard about you is
when you scam me for 3K off of such and
such Kick app
are you serious you kept following me
after you thought yeah that's a real
loyalty though he was like I'm
just say I've never ever ever accepted
money never did anything never shipped
nothing when I was a kid I tried to ship
pack one time and as I'm doing it go
this is stupid and not worth my time
yeah I've never shipped a package right
I was like you know what this is I
didn't even ship it
what am I doing I already tweak when the
packs are coming in dude I don't know
how hard I would tweak when they're
going out like I had a homie long time
ago I had a homie lose a a box in the
mail oh
100 pounds oh oh I made by box like a
box like he lost the box in the mail and
I remember for like four days he's like
pale like a vampire just like I'd be
told I mean even if it's a rack a pack
still lost 100K right bro not even the
cash value I mean worried about doors
getting kicked three days later it
showed up
no way don't don't get that box yeah
don't pick that box no no not even to
his house at the post office and said
hey your box is here please come grab it
oh that's how they get that's how they
get you as soon as you walk in like oh
so back in the day I had a PO box and I
gave out the address to viewers to get
mail but I was also getting packs like
to my P.O box oh yeah I remember this
yeah I think we talked about a little
bit so that's how they got me that's why
they didn't know they never like
actually got me I closed the PO box
after that but they called me one day
when I was waiting on my next like drop
off and they told me they were like hey
we have a package for you just come sign
for it at the desk and they've never
done that before so I never called them
back they left me a voicemail and that's
how I knew it was weird I was like bro
nobody at the post office cares enough
to leave exactly they do like they hate
their job they don't care enough yes
they don't care enough so whoever just
called me is getting paid enough to give
a [__] and that's scary
than that my homie just let me know in
California in certain leases read your
lease the people if you have gardeners
or anybody that does maintenance on your
house they I don't know what the program
was called but my homie Tyler just told
me about it because the guy snitched
basically snitched on himself
gardeners and houseworkers get paid 250
dollars if they see anything in your
windows in your backyard that could
break your lease
so my homie said that there's this
policy that you have a 48-hour notice to
get out because you get bongs and plans
right automatically eight hours 48 hours
and it's in your it's 250 to any worker
that reports somebody
snitching for two weeks though to be
fair though wouldn't you make more than
that 250 from just continuing to do the
job if they live there a hundred no no
they don't care because they're doing 30
yards a day like always got true and I
guess it's the landlord probably paying
them so it doesn't matter 100 it's
already like a so the guy said my homie
Tyler's like I talked to the dude when I
was moving out
and he like I'm like yo what's up bro
what's going on like I gotta be honest
bro
this is what they do this is your
landlord and he snitched on them like so
your language been trying to pay me to
get you out of here
anything he could do because he knows
you smoke even though it's illegal here
but in the policy he's like in the very
bottom of your contract it says anything
stated by a worker can get you kicked
out no lawyer no that's crazy fighting
it your lease I never heard of that
either yeah I've never seen that in my
life I'm like yeah right fool and then
my homie showed me in his contract like
wow you're not lying so read your
contracts I was not just his landlord I
said it's a comment it's a California
thing that it's a landlord law or law
for homeowners so they have the right to
do you have the right to do that wow if
it's in your contract so that's just
something pretty that's crazy I thought
that was wild so when you move out here
yeah dude thank you for telling me yeah
we're moving in like six months man are
you really yeah my so my lease ends in
September early September yeah I'm out
so what are you thinking
um I don't know I don't really know I
definitely don't want to be like you
know very close to the city or anything
I'm thinking after we get off I will
show you exactly where you need to move
okay okay show me I was thinking like
exactly where you need to go thinking
like Van Nuys or something like that van
is where I got my other Warehouse it's
really nice yeah yes yeah I was so I was
riding over there the other day
um because Attila is like kind of in
that area and we were driving through
it's like one road is nice and then the
next one over is like tweaker HQ not
hood hood yes yes Whole Foods yup yeah
yeah maybe there's a tweaker outside
like oh that's a beautiful Target oh
crack then you know exactly it's like
it's like uh it's America yes yes except
for where he lives everywhere everything
in his whole town is so nice and it
looks like the beginning of Kindergarten
Cop when everything's real good still
like except for the mall scene sorry you
never seen that movie nope oh hold on
hold on hold on
before we started speaking there was a
discovery we discovered something Marty
yes you have never seen the movie Friday
no I haven't we had it happens when we
said Friday you go what Oh you mean so
let's say the words Ice Cube what comes
to mind first well I know who Ice Cube
is you're nine years younger than me
right what was that movie he did
um oh my God it was are we there yet or
something like that yes that's what
comes to mind for me bro that was my
generation yes so that's the Ice Cube
movie that comes to mind for me I'm it's
it's are we there yet we had NWA Ice
Cube no yeah
we got Are We There Yet Ice Cube so we
didn't get the whole NWA all the the fun
ice cube we got the oh how oh that's a
that's a crazy person yeah what I think
of Ice Cube I think like PG movie you
know wow yeah what do you think what do
you think of iced tea
I don't think I can name anything that
iced tea is in honestly okay because
he's a cop and everything now but he
used to be cop killer really that's like
there was literally been an actor for
your generation right yeah well The Rock
the rest of that I still do I I still
watch WWE and play the games when I was
a kid okay I remember like um well I
think Hulk Hogan was a bit before my
time but we still like idolized him
because he was in all the games and all
the ads and stuff
um but I remember like when John Cena
was getting big seen him on the WB
really I stopped right before he really
I dude he was him back in the day
dude he would come in there he'd have
the cargo shorts yeah he'd walk in
pissed as hell like his character was he
cool was he good guy he was like sad
right he was kind of like I mean it
looked like he was like trying to be a
rapper yeah he was like he was kind of
like old Mark Wahlberg
exactly what I said the white dude you
know pulls up the jeans he's in shape
rap yeah Mark Wahlberg yes yes yes
that's pretty much who John Cena was
going so when you think Mark Wahlberg
you think of Mark and Mark well kind of
but because of what I know about him now
but like when I was younger and
everything I just thought of him as like
you know that normal action movie guy
and stuff like that
um that's such a crazy perspective so
you've never seen Friday next Friday
Friday After Next no no it's gonna be so
fun for you it's such good show me these
movies
you're gassing these movies up to me man
I'm ready there's no need to guess this
I need to see ice cubes real acting
ability because I mean he's great are we
there yet it's not that's really a good
display of ability I wonder what kind of
check he got cut for that oh god let's
let's guess can can we google that yeah
how much did Ice Cube make on uh are we
there yet I'm gonna say 12 mil
I feel like more I'm saying because part
one probably wasn't that big part well
actually yeah it probably wasn't that
crazy of a budget either they're just in
a car I've never seen it I just remember
the girl she has braces and she's and
she's yelling at him yeah they're just
driving around in a car that's the whole
the whole movie pretty it's literally
just a road trip like they're just it's
just the kid the the movie is called are
we there yet because the punch line is
the kids
I've never watched it yeah and he's like
he's like no like you know
deal with the kids he's like no
see that pretty much is the premise of
the movie dude it's not that special
it's just like no
foreign
I feel like there's no way he made more
than 10 of the movie's earnings though I
don't know he was up there I don't know
what is an actor's average cut like what
like what percentage of a movie's
Revenue will an actor because don't they
pay them before the movie drops should
they get royalties took a pay cut to
take royalties on Titanic
um
yeah uh he's crushing bro I think yeah
did the same thing for Rockies but they
were his movies so it's like you win
anyway yeah we should make a movie it's
gonna happen let's make a movie it's my
one goal in life I have one cult classic
movie that I can always go that's us I
need my clerks one
I have to it's gonna happen eventually
the weed tuber movie is going to change
the game I don't even know if it's going
to be a Wii tuber like they have to play
those characters in it I think it's more
of it well no I I'm not saying it's
gonna be about but like oh then yes yes
yes you know that's what I'm I don't
know that's what I'm thinking real quick
before we continue uh uh I know you guys
are gonna wear watches I showed you
earlier for everyone out there yeah
Smarties Rolex is shining can I see
yours yes dope thank you damn it
actually I scratched the uh I scratched
the date class a little bit on accident
oh so you can't really fall no I don't
know what happened to it bro I scratched
it that's even worse I got a call from
the A.D the other day and they told me
they had a watch for me at 5 pm
so I call them the very next morning at
10 am on the open Watch is gone of
course it's gone I couldn't believe it
one minute later I I was shocked they
even called me honestly what is that ad
authorization
it's impossible to ever get a watch from
a real Rolex retailer because they
always have wait lists and if they call
you it's going to be a watch that's not
super great
um so I didn't realize it was exclusive
that was so damn hard to get that one
which which model is that updates
datejust oh yeah good luck yeah good
luck finding that right now so they they
called me I wanted a uh I told him
anything with a green face but it's
gotta be if it's a datejust it has to be
a 41 because I want bigger 36. yeah and
I feel like it's a little too small so
it still looks yeah don't get me wrong I
love it and I'm not saying it's like too
small but I want bigger you know after
wearing it for a while I want bigger
um and they had a 41 green face datejust
but I never got to see it so I don't
know like what it actually looked like
or anything just yeah I know my homie
just tone just got the green one with
the diamond on it or whatever oh by the
way I'm wearing Space Jam watch I got
when I was 11 years old that thing is
sick that's the sickest watch at the
table oh I brought it just so I can go
hey
look at this Bugs Bunny spinning the
ball let's go I got this when I was 11.
it has a monster's band I will never
wear it again the amount of stuff you
have from your childhood like just like
a great condition is ridiculous I have
like none of my childhood belongings oh
I have every and now I gotta be honest I
might just take it off right now it's
like it's not I hate this what's
uncomfortable about it
what if I slam my hand ow well I mean
that would hurt with any watch no I mean
I'll break it damn it hurts oh yeah true
true I'm very animated when I speak so I
feel like hey I broke my Rolex on my new
rig and now they're both [__] dude you
know like that's my my luck you know
what I just remembered is completely off
topic go so you remember earlier I was
telling you how my dad is racist okay
because we said my dad's moving the
Friday surprise I've never seen Friday
yes well the reason I hadn't seen Friday
because my dad he had a massive
collection of movies like only Steven
Seagal before I was born my mom used to
tell me he had like an entire room in
the apartment that was just filled with
movies and one day a bunch of like
people broke into the apartment and
stole his movie collection and it was
like probably the most devastating
moment of his life you know
um so he always growing up he like
rebuilt it with like more stuff so when
I was a kid the entire living room bro
like the every wall in the living room
was just movies floor to ceiling like
crazy
wouldn't say hoarder there was like
Gamers yes like semi-organized you know
like he probably didn't know where
everything was but also it didn't look
like it was disorganized so he's a
racist
well my loves movies so my whole dad's
side of the family is like super racist
like that's that's just kind of how they
are uh and growing up I didn't really
realize it at first until I got older
and started picking up on like the
things they were saying and being like
Oh that's racist my grandpa used to
complain at the grocery store in the
neighborhood was too dark and I thought
he meant the lights but he didn't mean
the lights so they were like real like
old school racist but what I was gonna
say I just remembered so my uncle on my
dad's side of the family was an inventor
and he was super successful he made um
he invented if you can Google him
actually he's on the Wikipedia and stuff
he invented um like Blackberry like the
SMS technology he developed that and um
Verizon and like a bunch of other
companies kind of stole the tech from
him when he had the patent so he sued
them and died during the lawsuit and his
wife was a woman she was um I think I
don't remember what she was Latina I
don't remember I don't know where she
was from but she had like a very thick
Act accent and my dad's side of the
family was always terrible to her like
super awful so her husband my uncle died
during the lawsuit they settled the
lawsuit for 600 million right out of
that they got 200 million right she
takes the money writes my entire dad's
side of the family a check for ten
thousand and one dollars so they have to
pay tax and never speak to them again
never speak to them again no one knows
where she is no one knows what she's up
to but she's
[__] rich and I haven't spoken to my
anyone on my dad's side of the family in
like six years but the last time that I
was like it was every family gathering
since that happened
every time they're like where's our
money like we should be in a mansion
right now you know awesome that the
races got [__] bro they got [__] I
remember sitting there and I was like
you guys really asked for it you know
wow like I don't know what they really
expected the woman that they were awful
to the entire time she knew them do you
have a lighter I was actually does
anybody wider we're [__] up right now
I gotta be honest I lost it in the light
I got it ready cracked me in the
forehead he went I saw it coming back
I got it yeah when you held your hand up
because I I lost it you like you
shouldn't have moved the hand because
you would have deflected I pulled the
Sandlot and Dennis Leary
going to get me some frozen meat I loved
your face when you do that
first time I've been hitting them in the
face of the lighter
incredible oh it's yellow oh nice makes
sense why I lost it in the light yellow
pulled The Sandlot reference out all
that dude it cracked me right it was
perfect sorry your dad's race yeah
horribly racist and now still broke
because
they got screwed I love it dude it's
crazy I couldn't even imagine when
600 million total 200 million of it was
theirs how did he die
um I think it was like uh lung cancer he
he was a big cigarette smoker like big
time but he um
he uh that's a good wife yes yes did he
realize he was going to be getting this
money that he was not gonna see
um
well I don't think so this lawsuit was
like ongoing for a while I remember and
I was I was young as hell when he died I
was like 11 or 12. but I just remember
them always like talking about it but I
didn't really understand it at the time
um it wasn't until I got older and
looked up his Wikipedia page oh [__]
damn my uncle was that guy damn he was
him you know
um but I think like
towards the end we just all like like
once he actually like was in the
hospital with lung cancer and everyone
knew like he probably wasn't gonna make
it
um I think everyone in the family just
assumed that the money was going to be
dispersed among all of us haters hoping
he doesn't pull through and [__] well it
wasn't even that because if he was alive
he would have given like the rest of the
family money gotcha but he was like the
odd one out like he wasn't like the rest
of my dad's side of the family like he
wasn't racist you know like he wasn't
like them obviously not man he was a
chill ass dude he had a sick ass train
set Bro
he had a whole thing that he built
himself this like custom like uh it was
in his basement his whole basement it
was like maybe a thousand square feet
just one big train set with like
multiple trains going on you could
control them with these remotes and they
had like stops in the buildings had
lights you could turn on and off and
stuff 100
there was one guy in Merced that had you
can see it through his window and you
can see the triangle around his house
I've always wanted one of those but I
don't have the patience my grandma got
me when I was a kid and I was like put
the track together yeah
about that one yeah yeah
I didn't watch it but no that's the most
old school like let me get away from my
wife you know extended time
have you ever been to the Science and
Industry Museum in Chicago no if you
like train sets they have the craziest
one I've ever seen where it's literally
a one like one-to-one replica of Chicago
like the whole city and it's like exact
too like all the streets all the
buildings like it's exactly
um and I don't it's like super big I
don't know exactly how big it is but
what did you say did you say you ever
seen Beetlejuice yes another deep
reference because all I kept thinking
was that noise like this process what
you said everything I was like wait what
the [__]
I just hit click I got hit in the head I
have trauma
no go to the go to the Science and
Industry Museum in Chicago and look at
the train set someday it's incredible
dude I promise if I ever go I will leave
a sack of weed in one of the cards yes
bro yes hold me to it if I ever go we
should do like uh hit me up when you
come out we'll do like a Chicago stash
and dash and we'll stash it at like all
the museums we'll do one so Chicago's
Museum lineup is Rod I went to what
which one sorry I was in New York
bro I'm telling you the Chicago Museum
game is no joke well yeah like oh look
at Ferris Bueller yeah a bunch of them
yeah dude it's all the knowledge and
they're all good bro like I don't even
like learning bro
I don't want to walk like learn like I
don't want to walk in the museum because
usually museums are boring dude like you
know it's all information and there's no
fun but like the Chicago Museums do it
right they make the information fun you
know like that's an interesting too
they'll tell you about some history and
they'll be like yeah here's this dead
guy here's this dead Warrior right here
and then they'll have us like actual
corpse with the sword he had whereas
like you know you'll go oh I'd be happy
what if I was a warrior and you just put
me in the middle of a place where kids
are just tapping on my glasses where the
hell are the rest of his homies in the
ground
exactly so at least he is immortalized
right he's like reppin is set forever
they're always know about his group of
Warriors if and if it weren't for him
they'd just be dirt
hold on I gotta I gotta I got a question
that's true so we just Unearthed the
tombstone in my backyard what
I want to get your take on this we're
putting my pool in and we uncover a
tombstone any lights flicker in it no no
activity the other way
now do it that way
shouldn't have gone what
uh
concerning the uh Supernatural
if you were to have if you were to buy a
house put your life savings into it you
go to do the backyard you start digging
it up and stuff and you find
that it's a burial ground and that
there's caskets in there from before the
house was built oh there's caskets like
in there not in my house but this is now
a hypothetical okay question I'm getting
to
so you find caskets in your backyard now
you gotta take them all out your
backyard's a cemetery is that enough to
get you to move out of the house but I
already spent my money in and yes I'm
already hold on and hung up your TVs
that's a big thing I'm desecrating that
bro I'm [__] that grave up if I
already burnished it and everything
we putting a pool in oh we don't give a
[__] you're not thinking twice about it
well so here's the thing
um can I see a lighter by the way we're
we're uh oh okay I didn't realize so
many joints and I my lighters yeah I've
been talking for so long I just went
outside too
it's okay so you're gonna stay yeah I
can't revive it um
well like dude you can't sell the house
in good conscious and not tell the next
person
so you'd have to tell the next person
which really is true then the value goes
down by some golf [__] so you just
truth like yo you guys all want to live
in a house together give me all your
money where are the rich goth [__]
who are ready out here in L.A The Goth
[__] in Illinois smoke meth dude it's
not like here
it's like here too but they got buddy
well yeah sure sure you know they smoke
meth responsibly here not in Illinois
they spoke your lifestyle yeah
you got methyl lifestyle you're not
doing good if you're recreationally
smoking man yeah you're in shape yeah
recreational anything is fine
everything's a good moderation you know
what they say
you know everything's good in moderation
I mean I've never tried meth dude I got
a comment the other day from some guy
and he was like you know I really hate
the way Goblin uh oh
I really hate the way Goblin talks down
about meth like it's not that bad well I
should try it and I'm like bro I I
replied to him and I was just like what
do you want me to do suggest it like you
want me to do we want to do it like yeah
you guys should honestly pack a bowl
pack a little Pookie or something like I
was in uh Houston
and somebody came up and goes yo tell
Global to do cocaine again I go no he's
healthy he's like doing better with his
life he goes don't sacrifice bro that's
what he said take the guys on the video
no guy who came up to me you're like
he's probably not going to die now and
he's like but just sometimes you guys we
need those videos that's what he said
it's like yo yuru race bro
insane it's kind of like the guy who
came up to me at your Meetup with the
bag of blow oh yeah
it's all right yeah no oh my God no I'm
not doing that coke I'm not doing that
coke he walks up to me and he's like
I've been up for a couple days that's
like he's like I took meth sir well he
was telling me he took like three
Adderalls that morning and then started
doing blow and I'm sitting there and I'm
like bro your heart's probably dumping
right now dude like is your little inner
Coke demon just going crazy or is that
kind of gone now kind of gone I don't
really I mean I all my friends back home
are still cokeheads like most of my
friends still do that every day you know
so when we get together like I'll be
sitting there taking dabs off the rig
and we'll have the little smoke set up
and then they'll just be chopping lines
on the same table you know but yeah no I
say yeah the homies are chilling
oh yeah thank you don't get me wrong if
they got a nice rock like I'll scope it
out but
um smell [__] all day oh I can't no I'm
not gonna smell it I can't I can't get
once I get that high piercing smelling
oh and then I'm done I don't want to do
it at all dude I'm not gonna lie in
Vegas me and uh me and Eric we were uh
walking back to the room it was like 3
A.M and I was wasted and we stopped in
the bathroom to take a piss and I'm
walking out and this guy goes past me
and he goes Yayo and I was really
tempted dude I scoped it but I didn't
what was that what's in there oh yeah I
don't know I scoped it though I scoped
it it looked if it doesn't have a shine
like snow in the movies I don't want to
see yes but also I feel like there's
ways to fake the shine too no it's my
homies they always get the the bricks
and I always see them break it and I'm
like it looks like when when girls break
rocks they start conversating big
contributing factor to why I stopped
because my guy who would do that is in
jail and the guy who my my homies are
buying from now is like some random dude
yes no drugs yeah smoke weed yep yep too
many people die of Overdose rooms I go
to high school there's been two kids in
this past month out of that isn't that
crazy bro funerals really
in the past month freshmen what do they
OD'd off I seem like fat press pills
yeah yes God knows they probably didn't
even know they were taking fence yeah
that's crazy dude imagine your 13 year
old self right now ready
now there's fentanyl introduced bro when
I was younger yeah I would have died
when I when I was younger and I was
popping pills yeah I would have died 100
but I was fortunate enough to be in the
generation right before fentanyl was big
like fentanyl existed back that's what
I'm saying 2015 2016 but it was not
common no people were cutting pills with
[__] like it wasn't it wasn't [__]
that was gonna get you high they were
putting in pills you know the biggest
cut you had to worry about was buying
Flats because that was probably gonna be
meth you know but like you didn't have
to worry about vent or anything no
wonder what that was you know I was a
kid I could always I could smell it go
oh that's cut
how long until you started testing it
all the time
oh I didn't start testing anything until
I was like 21.
roll the dice yeah shooting every time
but I don't know I um I was stupid
enough for a long time to trust my plugs
blindly you know just be like oh that's
my plug he's alive yeah I saw you post
something on Amazon about getting on
Adderall on Amazon oh yeah yeah that was
fake yeah oh it's a fake yeah it's just
yeah someone sent me that and I was like
yeah that's funny I'm gonna just tweet
it you know um and a bunch of people
were in my replies being in there
bro so I uh I tried to get my Adderall
script back and I got denied
only like we've seen your videos Sir
yeah well so I've been going to the same
doctor for my Adderall for like 10 years
at least right and I go in this time and
apparently now it's a problem that I
smoke weed and take it but it never was
before and they've known I've always
smelled I was taking hard drugs back in
the day and they were still giving me
that script you know so like
they they were trying to give me and I
think there's a rumor going around that
there's an Adderall shortage right now I
don't know how accurate that is
um I think doctors are just trying to
like not prescribe it as much anymore
because it's meth you know yeah
um but I was trying to get it back
because it really actually works for me
like I do actually have ADHD and I need
that when you say it's meth like it's
I'm not even just straight upper it is
one chemical change away from math like
one molecule change away from math so
what does it feel like when it kicks in
you're deep it makes me um you're geeked
so it I feel like people who don't need
it feel it differently for sure for me
I'm just super alert I'm almost like
tunnel vision where if I'm like let's
say I'm talking in like writing
something down you know I'm gonna be
locked in staring at each key I'm typing
I'm gonna be typing double my normal
speed probably gonna be cold sweating
you know I'm gonna be like very
uncomfortable if I'm gonna be efficient
you know I'm gonna get but you're not
enjoying yourself oh no it's not fun but
for me it's not I have a lot of friends
who would disagree with that but I think
the difference there is they never
needed it for its actual medical use was
like that helps for me
um
but also like I have gotten geeked off
it but I have to do a lot more than like
my script I always prescribed a stupid
amount of Adderall I had um
so I was prescribed 70 milligrams a day
a 30 milligram extended in the morning
then I would get home from school and
they were giving me the description I
was like 13 bro I was geeky so they're
like you're on this all day now yes dude
so I would take it a 30 milligram XR in
the morning then I would go home and
take a 20 instant and then like three
hours later I'd pop another 20 instant
and that was my script every day so I
was getting like 90 pills a month
um and it after a while like I would
just give them to my friends I wouldn't
even charge exactly I used to bring them
so at my school I I went to like a
pretty decently nice high school when we
had a little weight room in there you
know and for gym class and junior year
they would let us go to the weight room
so me and my friends would go snort
Adderall in the locker room and go like
[__] try to lift as fast as we could
before the Adderall wore off
that sounds fun yeah oh it's fun as a
kid
as a kid that sounds great I got to be
honest but not anymore as an adult no no
got [__] to do yeah I'll live sober I'll
lifts over I like getting high as I
possibly can and getting and then
lifting so you go in there and say it's
hard for me to pay attention as a kid
and they say we're gonna get you on this
24 7 for the rest of your life they um
Adderall wasn't the first like
medication I got I I had tried other
stuff but it didn't really work
um Adderall was the first one that I was
prescribed that actually worked so after
I got it I just like for a long time
never really stopped the script I had it
for probably like five years straight
and then I finally after I dropped out
of high school stopped taking it pretty
soon after because I was like well you
know I don't need it but I'm still
getting my script just to like hoard
them you know because I was like well
people people yeah dude Idol's time oh
my you know how much I have 30 XR goes
for it finals bro
oh easy like 15 up minimum dude 15 a pot
minimum so you're keeping yourself alive
just selling the [__] you don't even
want one the only way I'm getting 15 to
pop is from um I somehow I managed to
sneak my way into getting placed in a
like AP class an honors class in high
school uh it was AP Government
and dude awful whack class awful class
that was let's learn about more do you
remember uh when I told you that story
about the chick I accidentally sent that
dick pic too that was AP Government yeah
AP Government those kids were all
geekers dude because they had to do real
homework so I wasted everything so
naturally I was like you need this no I
don't you need that no you need knee
braces when you lift do I do I really
so when I was thinking about like I had
AP I was in the gifted and talented
education classes remember that yes yeah
yes I was in all the well what happened
the story is
in the 70s and 80s I guess you could
beat the shed of your student and like
it was fine yeah
dude so there was a lady named Miss
morning she's like six two black lady
from the south oh he's gonna back you up
she's like Barry [__] down she'd
probably still [__] you up honestly she
was so I know you oh well when you watch
Friday you ever seen from Sanford and
Son Esther she looked like Esther from
San Francisco the lady the half dead
[__] from the beginning of
Friday
she looked like her her name is Miss
morning I went to fourth grade
uh her son was my aunt Pepper's friend
and then it turns out they were at a bar
he punched my aunt prepper in the face
and then got jumped by a bunch of guys
that's all I knew about going into this
okay okay so I go to school and I'm like
all right Miss morning I'm polite I'm
very respectful she loved me but she
went off on some kids and I was like is
she gonna hit them
I went home told my mom my teacher was
and my mom's face like went white like
who did you say turns out she used to
beat the [__] out of my mom in class in
the 70s and 80s when my mom was a kid
because my mom was a dick so I guess she
used to beat the [__] out of my mom in
class when you're allowed to hit him
with rulers still
my mom went the next only proactive
thing she ever did for my schooling she
went the next morning and was like
you're getting out of the class and they
told him you're not getting out of the
class unless you want to move schools
that's where he's going to be and like
test him again put him in a different
school and they tested me about your
kids so [__] smart you're right you
got to get him out of this class and
that's how I got into the stupid GATE
program with all the smart kids with
tons of [__] homework and you really
have to watch it well she always hated
it it's so ass I hated it and like a
year or two later Malcolm in the Middle
came out and I'm like that's how I feel
I was just a regular kid and now with
all the smart kids I [__] hate it and
some witness protection type [__] I felt
like this looking through the fence like
all your recess is a different mind [__]
I hated it so the smart kick class the
AP kids [__] all that [__] yeah [__]
those classes but some of the kids in
there chill and they buy a lot of Addy
they're Breakers so the third grade I I
convinced everybody to let me out they
gave me AP English and government I went
there's no way in hell I'm reading a
book by next week and I told him hey you
can kick me out of the class or I'm just
gonna get an f and they let me out of
all my AP classes and never had to go
back let's go yeah W yeah same with my
Spanish Spanish teacher she got so
pissed at me she let me out of the class
dude I failed Spanish like four times
bro I still only know like maybe five
words
like if even you know bro come on I
should know yeah you're my family my
future my family never taught me it's
their fault their fault but I took
Spanish and then and then I moved to
Oregon and they had different
curriculums so my Spanish was already
like marked off for my 10th grade year
so when I went back I never had to take
Spanish oh [__] dude it's it's so bad I
I really need to learn it because
Emily's parents only speak Spanish like
they don't speak English like Puerto
Rican
um
Costa Rican and Cuban her dad is Cuban
her mom is Costa Rican but they're both
neither of them were born in America
they're both like from those places so
um Cuban makes no sense now yeah so um
her dad speaks more English than her mom
her dad like I can talk to her mom
literally doesn't know what I'm saying
so like I also have like very little
I've started to pick up on some you know
phrases and stuff but like I also rarely
have any idea what she's saying so she
just like she's one of those like kind
of Angry Moms where like she won't yell
at me she's yelling at her but she's
yelling at everyone and I think she's
pissed and I don't know about what so
I'm sitting there
[__] dudes my childhood I really wish I
knew what she was saying I I regret
failing Spanish four times oh you went
back forward to Spanish one bro I took
Spanish one four times it was a seventh
grade eighth grade ninth grade tenth
grade I took Spanish and I failed it
every single time lack of trying so
seventh grade yeah I didn't try eighth
grade
um I was like dating some chick in the
class and she would let me cheat off her
task but I got caught so I got you know
I failed
um ninth grade
I kind of tried but I just like I just
couldn't do it was the different
languages just like don't compute I get
it um I wish I picked it up as a kid
yeah yeah me too me too our uh Spanish
class when you walk in once you're in
the class you cannot speak English
anymore but day one how the [__] do I
know yeah how would you ever do that how
do I know what you're [__] saying
literally unless you say Thomas I don't
know that you're talking to me yeah
that's why I'm here and I I made a huge
scene in class because every time she
would start screaming at me stop
speaking English and I go you just spoke
English and then share her face like
she get real pissed day three she said
wait for way after class of me making I
caused I'm an [__] when you're an
[__] to me I'm a concert I'm a I'm I
feel that I'm such a little bastard I
feel that yeah I'm like you're gonna hit
me [__]
so let's continue and then she stayed
after class and she's like what do I got
to do to get you out of my classroom and
go sign the paper I gave you yesterday
she signed it and let me like Matilda on
her back we're going to Guam yeah
starting my [__] [__] so I can get out
of here and that was it I just got Jim
two times oh let's go let's see bro
that's awesome we'll just put on shorts
and I gotta see yeah sick you should be
able to opt out of that it's like extra
harder
and then I did I had a Pals you have
Pals where you're at what is PALS Pals
is the classroom of all the uh because
it might have Down syndrome or learning
disability okay so we had something like
it but it wasn't like was it called it
was a program like an after-school thing
oh no it was a class I had that class
for like eight years straight it was
sick damn all we do is hang out with
these kids what can I do to make your
ass laugh today and that was it I played
Blitz with this dude Blanco for like two
and a half years straight bro it was
sick we just like that's all that sounds
like the best ever what but I'm like
running in circles like you got me
I'm so good at Blitz I shouldn't picked
Blitz to play with you because you know
what I mean like I'm trying to let him
win I'm like uh I'll score 30 points
first and then I'll let you catch up or
something like well I mean I feel like
it's good for you to win sometimes too
you gotta teach them how life goes you
know I mean I'm doing this with camera I
got a PS5 by the way I'm online
NBA I've been going through this with
Cam UFC I respawn my NBA skills so now I
gotta let him pick my team he gives me a
bunch of 1970s white point guards and I
got above against him with Giannis and
LeBron and Durant have you been playing
career mode on 2K no we I just got the
online two days ago okay and now I'm
figuring it out I went online on GTA 5
for the first time it's so sick bro it's
sick but also you're gonna get [__] on
by those hiring dudes for so long
because that happens to me still I don't
play it enough and there's these high
ranked dudes and they got these flying
motorcycles with heat yeah and missiles
bro dude you can go to your bunker in
GTA Online and call in an orbital
missile strike on someone from your
house and it'll just blow them up like
wherever they are no and there's nothing
you can do about it cost a million
dollars to do but like your average
player like the the real Grinders have
like a bunch of money so that's nothing
but like when you just start Mill's a
[__] I gotta I just got to the bunker I
thought I was so cool I spotted somebody
on the map I came flying down in the car
slammed into them in the car I'm like oh
oh no I'm flipped over on the car they
take out a sticky bomb bro bro
I'm jealous that you're having your like
first GTA experience right it's hard
dude yeah it's hard playing I I told you
I played one time well these kids are
demons at it now I mean these kids have
been playing this game bro for like
almost like it's actually a decade it's
this look I'm really good GTA you know
driving while shooting out the window
popping fools hit the helicopter pilot
while you're driving correctly all that
fun stuff it doesn't work like that
online it is a different game online yes
I shot one guy shot at him oh and he
probably camped you he probably killed
you you got a helicopter
and he kept blowing me up I couldn't
cross the street a die respawn die
35 times yeah easily are you gonna give
up yet never never no you had to leave
it at that 2020 is the last time I
picked that game up online because I'm
like bro I I what do I do we could all
play GTA
and Squad up that sounds you can't get
killed awesome I want a helicopter
killed me but dude it's hard to like I
don't understand online I don't
understand the world the RP [__] I don't
understand so RP is way different I need
to get it it's almost there my whole
twitch room is ready to go except for
the knowledge of going all right so what
do you need to know though I can help
you with oh today you tell me what yeah
yeah I have the the gato
what's it called the streets
I have that it has all my buttons
everything done everything ready to go I
have a camera
so when you do the RP like DJ ghost has
his own my understanding it is you have
to like buy and own a server space no
you can just join a server okay no to
make your own world I think oh if you
want to make your own then yeah you
gotta buy and but making your own server
is like super complicated you have to
hire programmers to like continually
update and maintain the server you have
to hire
um people to administrate it you know
you're not really going to get
consistent good people to do that for
free you know
um and it's expensive to run those kind
of servers and also like it's really
tough to make a good one because to make
a good one you can't just use like
templates of other people's servers and
you know downloaded assets you have to
create your own scripts and create your
own like systems and and designs for the
service you have to hire like I thought
it was just GTA but I just wanted to
watch loaded screens run so if you want
to play GTA RP I'll show you how to do
it but you can't make your own server
unless you hire I know Omar has his own
world or whatever Franklin from GTA Sean
uh he lives right down the street for me
now I did all that he's right down the
street bro I went to his house the other
day and helped him set up his twitch
because he's about to start doing role
playing that's good that's Franklin on
Grand Theft Auto let's go it's just
gonna be the coolest ever because then
you get your are you like talking under
the controller it's like your voice when
you're playing RP you can't do it on
Console you have to do it on PC okay uh
you can play with the controller hooked
up to your thing
I wouldn't recommend it for you got it
you got to do this stuff to play kta if
you want to play GTA RP you don't want
to play a keyboard well I mean you don't
necessarily have to use a controller
correct
I wouldn't recommend it so you're saying
that if you play Grand Theft Auto online
you're going left right left no if
you're playing online like the regular
the role play yeah if you're playing the
role play keyboard if you're playing the
regular online yeah controller yeah you
can move with the up down run jump yeah
wasd fingers on wasd those are the Four
Keys you need
so if somebody wants to join your RP
that means that they can cut you can
like make yourself right that's the idea
if you want to yeah yeah you can um so
you can make someone that looks mostly
like yourself or you can have someone
make you like a custom skin that looks
like you
um which is usually the way to go but
people charge a lot of money like you
upload your photo and that's you type of
thing
um they'll make like a 3D model that
looks like you so like you'll send uh
you know somebody's able to do that kind
of stuff we can picture you and they'll
just make like a build out an actual
character there's a Portuguese team I've
seen a lot of people send me pictures of
me
as in the world I mean it doesn't look
just like me but it's like with the tree
shirt that's cool yeah I get it that's
awesome like that's how you can rock
your own clothes run around like yo yeah
they put straight shirt it's but I gotta
be honest it's like just being in the
real Earth
yeah except there's no consequences I
think you guys would love RP but yeah
it's it's complicated let's play myself
I just want to play crack it dude I just
sleep on stream just take a tweaker just
make a tweaker character could you
imagine being twacked but I speak very
articulate I mean that's my character on
there is like I made a big country dude
yeah like a hillbilly dude but he smokes
hella meth like I just cook meth yeah
so that's I mean that's in real life
it might be in real life but can't talk
about that but like that's why I'm
trying to lose weight yeah
um the character that like because you
have to make your own character and like
act as them you know so you kind of have
to create you know almost like a persona
for your your play character
um whether it's like you or not my guy's
nothing like me my guy's a country Duty
spokesman you know um so I'm from the
country Yeah well yeah but so right now
we could all like I don't this is basic
Elementary level of questions like we
could get some fans we could get us we
could all be on the GTA online world at
the same time trying to kill each other
or like playing defense against however
many people are in that online world yes
yes how many people are in that when you
spawn into a GTA online like how many
people are there many
on regular like on PlayStation and stuff
usually
I don't know what the exact number is
but I think it's like 20 a Lobby or
something
uh think something like that
it's a two grand bucket dosido dosipop
I'm about to throw this in this joint oh
roll smoke match with the
I know but this is like
something we want to cherish or do you
want to roll it in here bro I have
probably 30 bucks of that at home never
mind okay do you have a key sir can you
keep speaking I just wanna you know I'm
about to roll a chopper of a chop I just
wanted to do it while you're on the show
now housekeeping kept trying to barge
into my room this morning no I had to do
not disturb sign on the door and they
tried to come in and I was like what the
[__] so I told him some lady opened the
door she was like hello she's like get
out
I was laid in bed I was like sleeping
bro they woke me up and then the manager
came to my door like 45 minutes later
and they're like you still checking out
today and I was like what I don't leave
till Thursday bro so I was like what are
you talking about they're like well we
had this room marked as vacant and I'm
like why bro like I just checked in
yesterday you know so she told me to
contact the front desk about it so I
called the front desk
and I talked to one girl on the phone
and she's like um yeah I don't know why
they said that you know your
reservations until Thursday
um and I I'm like okay so I'm all good
and she's like yeah you're good to go
and then she hangs up then I get a call
on my phone 10 minutes later I'm just
trying to sleep bro all this this all
this has happened this morning yes and
then I get a call on the phone 10
minutes later and someone else some
other woman calls me and she's like
um are you not like checking out today
and I'm like bro what are you talking
about and she's like well you came to me
yesterday and said that you wanted to
shorten your reservation to Monday and I
I was like no I didn't I checked in
yesterday like what are you talking
about then she just kind of paused
and she was just like oh there must have
been a mistake or bad and just hung up
this is not like a motel six no bro I'm
at like a nice hotel I met a [__] um
you can say where you are because it's
gonna be later it's not a Hilton it's a
uh oh what the [__] is it called dude I
can pull it up take a [__] on him real
quick I am gonna [__] on them dude
because it's actually in a concerning
area and I didn't realize that the
hamstery area bro Tweakers across the
street all night long making noise oh
um the Hampton Inn okay here we go I'm
about to start oh
oh let's go so here we're going good
good good continue I got a question for
you I pulled one of your tweets here I'm
hoping it has to do with uh rosin here
I'm hoping you can break this down
before you can continue I was gonna do
this I'm like I was just about to ask
Marty can you ask him something if I saw
an episode of Tyson remember he started
rolling or smoking Johnny Goes yo
ask him some [__] and then he started
enjoyment one day I'm gonna
somebody ask him some [__] that just
smells like that here's my chance all
right
this is Goblin on Twitter I tried to
break a certain device by overflowing it
with rosin but it never broke so I ended
up smoking like a grandma rosin in 30
minutes yeah so I yeah I did a video
recently
um and I had this little like pocket
Dabber and I was just trying to break it
you know I was kind of like just trying
to find the excuse to get faded so I was
sitting there and I was like well how
much Rosa would I have to cram in there
for it to like stop working you know so
I decided to find that out so I started
with like small dabs and I kept taking
progressively bigger ones until
literally the whole chamber bottom to
top was I dropped like a [__] I don't
know how much dude but a huge ass dab
and it was like some of the best rosin I
had because I wasn't expecting it to
last that long so I'm sitting there and
I took like probably like five Dabs out
of it I don't remember it was four or
five
um but they were like it wasn't a very
big chamber you know the dab chamber is
maybe like that size you know pretty
tiny
um but I I just completely filled it up
and it just kept chugging until finally
at the very end of the video it gave out
I ended up smoking like
I mean I didn't scale it but it was
definitely at least a gram because it
was a two grand pug and that [__] was
ran through like that was damage bro
critical condition like it was bad oh my
God can we just can we just it looks
like artwork can we just look at this
old hash I know you can't see everybody
driving but is there Helios in there too
yeah I dumped that in the middle oh so
there's at least
1.4 1.5 a hash in there let's go
what a great start to the day honestly I
woke up recently finally I woke up well
I mean I woke up earlier than that but
then I went back to sleep well they kept
bugging you yeah those [__] dude now
have you been on your your Fitness shop
like you I saw you posting about eating
healthy and losing yeah so I've been on
a diet I haven't been uh really like
working out that much
um I'm a lazy [__] still at the end of
the day but um I have been on a diet and
it's been working pretty well nice um
I'm not really following any particular
like
you know diet I'm not like keto or
anything but it's more so just like
eating healthier things a lot of grilled
chicken broccoli
um no fried foods you know not drinking
like soda only water stuff like that
um it's been working yeah I'm down shirt
size already good [__] dude yeah it's
been working I used to work with this
really famous nutritionist Mike Dolce
Dolce Diet and he it was almost like
disheartening he's like it's like
90 diet you're talking about weight loss
I'm like no but what like I like to
exercise once I get into exercise and
I'm really into it he's like
it's like 95 see the important thing is
is being able to get enough of your
daily like nutrients but still having a
bit of a calorie deficit when you want
to lose weight
um so I've been like dude I've never
read nutrition labels in my goddamn life
you know but I've I've started actually
like paying attention to the amount of
like sodium and and trans fats and you
know different types of sugars and
things you know because some sugars are
good
[Music]
um and just learning about stuff like
that but yeah I've just been uh on the
salad and raw chicken or not raw chicken
grilled chicken not raw okay um salad
grilled chicken and you know rice kind
of grind a lot of tuna too tuna's op
dude tuna's protein what does LP stand
for overpowered so put that in your
Tweet it's a diet has been opium
man diet's overpowered dude the first
time you came here you were talking
about how many how much drugs you do now
you're like I'm looking at sodium and
trans fats look at see Evolution growing
up Evolution yeah who would have thought
huh who would have thought you would
have started on this little Charmander
when you were coming into Charizard I
like it you said you're looking for your
Warehouse
so yes your can you please tell us about
that because you've talked about it one
time so you and Eric posted it too yeah
so me Eric and Attila Attila from cubis
uh for those of you guys watching out
there
um we created a company together so
we've already it's like a real
registered LLC it's kind of cool we even
got like the uh bank account with the
little debit card yeah
um but yeah we we want to create weed
products you know we want to create
different ways for people to smoke
um we want to create different ways for
people to get faded I feel like a lot of
times when I hit [__] like an e-rig and
I I hit like you know different pipes
and like bubblers that are out now I'm
sitting there and I'm thinking to myself
like
this could be cooler yeah you know like
the current e-rig scene everything's
just a triangle on a base you know like
make something sicker than that it's not
hard you know so we want to do that um
it's not just e-rigs that's like the
long term goal but obviously we can't
just jump straight into making a e-rig
um but it's just general weed products
and and [__] that we come up with you
know to solve problems it's it's more of
a company that we made because it's like
you know there's so many inconveniences
that we have when we're smoking instead
of waiting for someone else to solve
them and then paying for it you showed
me at the event that I saw him at what
was that the uh secret sash it's all
like little inventions and like looks
like a little modern the isopropyl
station it was like a bunch of little
gadgets yeah so one of the one of the
things that we're dropping first I guess
we could talk about this because it's
coming the soonest
um we're making little isopropyl
stations uh where you can like put your
bangers and your marbles and you can uh
lift it out of the isopropyl and lock it
yeah lift it out lock it into place so
your shit's not dripping anywhere
getting wet
um because all the other similar stuff
on the market right now you're just
dripping you got to get the little
Diamond Grabber yeah yeah that oh we
should include that that would be sick a
little bundle you know throwing a
diamond Grabber I actually don't have
one of those yet I just got one mine
broke yesterday bro they're so sag dude
they're awesome
I've just been sticking my hands in the
iso for so long yeah like same you know
what else we all do yeah so what's it
look like as far as the shop goes like
is it live is it about to be live
um for fumo so right now we're not
selling anything we're still in the
early stages of product development oh I
just ashed on my own finger
um we're still in the early stages of
developing products and coming up with
new ideas the isopropyl is probably the
soonest thing we've already kind of we
know what we're doing we already have
you know examples of a maid
um I actually just got one from Attila
the other day which I'm very excited to
start using
um but we're we're mainly in the still
looking for a location product
development and once we get the location
really filling that out with like
putting Machinery in there putting
um you know computers in there I'm
putting a little little mini studio in
there so that's gonna be fun but just
making it chill so you know it's
inspiring to watch you guys off YouTube
and I'll make these videos yeah the the
early stages of it have been really fun
because you know I I told them you know
when we were sitting down and talking
about when we want to launch things I
said we're at the stage of the company
where we can take our time and make it
good but once we drop something we don't
have time for that you know like we have
to continue we have to like be
consistent so we're really taking our
time and making sure that like what we
do is perfect you know making sure that
we you have a consistent line of things
that
um
[Laughter]
just kind of making sure that we have a
consistent line of products that are
dope and and are worth people's money
are they going to be on like the more
expensive one
some yes
um anything that's got Electronics
involved probably yeah
um we're we're putting quality first you
know I I don't think we're really Mass
producing anything that's not our plan
um we're not making volume products you
know we're making stuff that's cool
stuff that people are gonna people are
gonna want
um and I understand that people want
more affordable stuff of course that'll
always be you know something that'll
happen down the line but I don't think
it's something we're for we're focused
on early on I think we're just focused
on making this sick of [__] are we gonna
see this this year come on 100 100
um
definitely probably sooner than a lot of
people think but yeah coming this year
yeah I'm excited about it man I've we've
been working on it for a while company
was uh registered back in October yes
it's been a minute yeah
that's smart it's like people don't
realize like no I've been working on
this for like two years we're this is
like yeah we had a plan behind this drop
we've been talking about it for a long
time even before uh like actually going
and making the company we had talked
about it for a while originally it was a
discussion that Attila and I had had he
was like oh I want to you know make this
new product and I told him I was like
it's bull correct
yes what he was talking about yes the
bull um and that's something that we're
still working on refining and making
better
um that's something that's gonna be a
part of fumo so that's gonna be a fun
one but we um
we were talking about that and I told
him I was like bro we should do some
[__] together you know like he's the
engineer he's really good at what he
does he's amazing at making products and
coming up with ideas but he is not the
greatest at marketing so I told him I
was like bro
you develop we're chilling you know and
then we were talking about it further
and we were like well what if he brought
Eric on board you know like Eric's he's
got connections he he's already doing
his thing with Anova and we need someone
to help us with glass stuff
um and Eric's also our good friend of
both of us so [__] it bring Eric on you
know now we got the homies and
um I mean a lot of people say don't
don't do business with your friends and
I I disagree with that for sure now
um I think when you have the right
business-minded friends yeah not every
friend no yeah oh no no not every I can
name a lot of friends I wouldn't do
business with a lot of friends that I do
business that I know do their own
business but I'm like also
I don't want to deal with the problems
yes yes yeah I dealt with that before
I'm like bro let's take the business
aspect out of it you're on time and
doing [__] how come when it involves our
[__] you suck like I'm not saying exact
friends but yes it's happened before
years just like
you gotta make me hate your [__] work
that's that's just my brain like if I
can get it done why can't you
that's all I feel that I feel like you
guys are all on the same page yeah yeah
I mean I'm I'm excited about it I think
um I think it's it's gonna be really fun
and I'm excited to make [__]
um for yourself that we want yeah that's
the coolest part you know we're sitting
here and we're coming up and it's like
we're not even considering like how many
people are gonna buy it or what's the
demand for this it's just like yo this
is something we want cook it up nice
thing yeah yeah that's the whole beauty
of having your own space yeah business
and your own bank and it's not with your
card game on it yes have your own space
having the freedom for our own ideas and
you know we we don't have any outside
funding you know we don't have any
people really telling us what to do and
we don't plan to
um we're kind of planning to to
self-fund ourselves so
you're like oh we split it between
ourselves yeah we're just like hey break
bread you know we were talking about it
we're gonna put like five percent to the
boat fund we want to buy a boat you guys
want to buy a boat yeah we're gonna get
a boat so we can go fishing and [__] I'm
gonna buy a nice boat go deep sea
fishing oh you guys are all down with
that that's scary dude what's wrong with
that are you down I don't [__] with the
ocean
I think we talked about this oh yeah no
ocean but like
I didn't like GTA
I'm not much of ocean man myself you get
me out there I'm
dude last thing I want to do is pull a
fish out of the water take a couple
grams of shrooms
lose my mind out to the ocean
this week we got the dopest fan oh we
got like uh I thought we were just
getting a van these fools are bougie and
are dumb for I it's expensive it's do
they get one of those like Sprinter fans
it's it looks like this inside
oh my God it's got Captain's chairs
I'm like yo this is sick and it's only
price go guys
why we all have cars
we all have nice cars give me a ballpark
because I feel like I'm damn near close
to the Maybach
damn
what
that's what I say go what'd you say I
thought we're getting a van
how often are you going to be in that's
what I said okay
what did we do we should do this before
the meet and greet Road tripped it to
the meet and greets that would have been
yes yes you know that feels like old
jackass uh CKY like old school style the
what's it called the gumball run or
whatever they did when they all raced
across the country or whatever it was I
get that but when you're saying like we
get into a company boat that's different
you guys like boats
this one the the dope is they're like
yeah we got this van I go sick I saw a
picture go how much was this organ van
guys yeah it has Beyond lights
everywhere that's all I can think of the
cost of cost like dude I don't want to
be driven almost as much as I want again
yeah you know that might be interested I
hate it actually yeah I want to be
driving if I'm in a car I'm driving I
don't know what it is but I don't trust
when someone else is whipping a vehicle
I'm in unless it's an airplane
then I'm definitely gonna trust
airplane's the only reason because I
can't control it
dude I kind of oh is this the no okay
that's not the oh wait oh that's a OG
joint I didn't want you to miss it
because that one was taking a while so
yeah try that
um
anyway yeah I can't wait for that van
video we're just got to be like the bang
bus and just call it something else by
go pick up people getting high as hell
though and they find their names on the
top like yeah do you think you can sit
here don't ask how I know that for 20
minutes
you gotta do something with it I don't
know something's got to happen it can't
just be like we're gonna go to dinner
but I I don't yeah you gotta like do
like a like a mini two or something
has to happen it's gonna be fun I think
it's a great idea
or you can do the talking with Thomas as
well there you go something something
like maybe it's a series in the car we
drop off to different that would be
spots something has to happen you gotta
do at least like a hot box in it oh
that's the first thing a good video but
it's just like when you said the boat I
go
bro you wouldn't want to smoke on a boat
no on the my homie Trent has a boat his
sister has a big ass bow and uh I step
foot on it and I was about 80 Seconds
and I go I'm out of here no I love bugs
dude votes are it well to me it's like
this you're on a car you're in a car
step out it's on fire cool what happens
to the boat catches on fire what the
[__] you gonna do you just step out and
die something to float in It's called
The Boat no bro there's life vest
there's rafts bro nobody's just riding
out this I ain't gonna put my feet
dangling in the water bro what do you
think it's Jaws you think like the Great
White's gonna come bite your head no at
all times I think that that's not going
there because of that especially I don't
care about us no bro I think it's gone
are you scared in playing sometimes yeah
what are the odds of that crashing very
low still scared
a lot of plane crashes have lived it's
I'm not worried about the the oh I'm
dead shark I'm worried about the I'm
getting eaten alive damn it versus the
oh [__] I'm falling off this you're more
scared of getting eaten alive than the
shark itself
yes because if a sharks were super
friendly I'd be like sick let's go
swimming so you're not scared of sharks
you're scared of getting eaten alone no
I'm scared of sharks because they don't
compete with humans they don't go hey
man you're cool I ain't gonna eat you
yeah they do no they don't they bite you
and those sharks are not always going to
swim up and eat you no no but would you
risk being in the pool with a shark what
kind of shark any shark you're gonna
jump in and go depends on the kind of
shark I don't care I'm racist against
sharks all sharks are bad you're racist
all sharks are bad whoa you know what I
saw last night I saw people fishing
Australia and it's like 15-foot shark or
like 12 foot shark swimming and like
look at it and a big ass great white
comes behind it eats its whole damn tail
bro and then the thing kept trying to
eat the stuff it didn't even care that
it just got bit the whole back of it's
gone and that made me think I don't care
about the water
if this is The Truman Show the
government's done a very good job of
keeping me out that way would you rather
get eaten by none no no you have to pick
a whale you have to pick shark alligator
alligator
why there's a shark I'm drowning also
true like at least I'm on the surface
hopefully
and I think I could take an alligator I
don't give a [__] if Captain Hook can
kill an alligator I'm pretty sure I can
kill an alligator
I will choke an alligator to death if I
really no bro aliens are like okay
give me all right
if you give me like a small Blade the
movie Blade no no no it's not like Blade
no give me a small blade and I could
probably like slit his throat you know
an alligator yeah yeah
it's like a little maybe even like a
like they're like pitbulls that are too
big they can't really do much in your
mouth but they can't do that death roll
thing you know yeah I'll roll all you
want we'll find out your headlock
I'm giving them a [__] sleeper hold
versus just half your body being missing
what's the other Joy did we smoke that
whole joint already
I think this is it you smoke both of
those already well I no I just had this
little one and then the other one was
being passed around Marty did I give you
a joy oh you smoked that one already
yeah oh that's where it is okay I think
they're doing good no we're doing fine
did I throw it away
this sir I'm concerned about it I don't
even know what to say or think because
we have some crazy rosin in that oh my
how heavy is the weight torch
oh my God right you have to like oh wow
here you go
check this out American with this yeah
yeah holy for sure I'm proud to smoke
this
all right so hold on
sharks alligators yes how did we get on
that I don't really I don't know fully
at all the spiders are [__] up boat
talk oh boats oh boats you guys want to
get a boat
it's like a ping pong ball with our
conversation or like the pinball and
just
or do we just all have ADHD I think of
well it's not a bad thing I found out
recently dude let me ask you do you have
inner dialogue oh yeah okay do you big
time like in my head yeah okay yeah do
you can you think of more than one thing
at once like right now
do you have a song always playing in
your head while you're having all the
same time
playing in my head until I'm sleeping
exactly right okay have you ever have
two songs almost trying to go that's the
worst oh bro my [__] yeah my [__] okay
uh Summer Love from Grease in my head
five hours straight never went away well
same part too while I'm cooking I'm like
why he's on repeat just a loop of ten
seconds yeah same 10 seconds over and
over and you don't even realize it's
there until like 4 P.M but it's just
been looping all day this morning
because last night I was watching a
piece of DMX going off on MTV I was like
yeah and then this morning I woke up and
stuck in my head so I just wanted to
make sure we're all on the same page
because I have a home and it's John that
has no inner dialogue and he had to tell
me what do you mean by that so I found
out John does not have inner dialogue at
all that's crazy I'm thinking about
because he doesn't multitask it's one
thing we know he don't talk if he's
talking don't talk ever watched a movie
don't ask him a question he will not
hear it his brains only does this
he's an NPC I told him that too like
he's actually like a boss that's what I
told him too I'm like dude so you don't
have a soul or something
it's not like as annoying as it is when
I've got like the same song going in my
head for four days straight at least I
know I'm okay I mean yeah at least I
know something's happening up there
because I think if it was dead silent up
there it would be much worse so I I
would probably go crazy scary like I
sometimes I feel like I'm sitting there
and I'm like bro if you put me in like
solitary confinement I'm fine yeah I'd
probably be okay it's not working I say
that all the time like what I'm gonna
get to sleep finally yeah like what
about what am I gonna do clock myself
again this is pretty positive the the
voice in your head dude it's like an
affirmative word dude I'll sit there and
like play games in my head all the time
I'll be like I'm not alone here just
fine thank God yeah I might sometimes I
thought it was crazy as a kid like why
are you talking to yourself dude
sometimes I've been asking yourself why
are you talking to yourself sometimes I
sit there and I wonder why it's like
that and I'm like am I schizophrenic all
the time dude my grandma was bipolar and
I'm like dude is that me is something
wrong with my brain why am I thinking of
five numbers and things falling at a
movie scene and a song yeah I'll think
of some numbers and then go bet on them
oh yeah I don't do that oh it works
sometimes though OCD it's actually
working the the roulette head I'll never
forget yeah uh with Eric uh yeah but
there was one time too I did it on um
what's it called on stake I remember
what game I was playing I think I was
playing a dice and I was just thinking
in my head like I was like yo it's gonna
hit this number you know like I'm gonna
go crazy so I did like a super like low
odds bet and I uh I hit it one time and
I won like two grand or something yeah
like one click yeah it was [__] do
you ever wake up think of a song two
seconds later hear it on the radio or
your phone yeah dude I feel like I
predicted [__] or movies that are old as
[__] and you walk into someone's house
like why are you watching yeah someone
will talk about it they'll be like I was
just thinking like it's crazy all the
time or I'll be thinking like I'll be
thinking about like maybe like something
I did with someone or like about someone
and then just hit me up they'll hit
they'll bang my line immediately like
all the time I was talking to like I was
thinking about one of my homies and uh I
was talking like one of my other homies
who was at my house at the time and this
dude we hadn't talked to him in like
three months four months you just
Snapchats me out of nowhere is you have
immediately we went bowling dude I made
a bowling team that night I got so faded
I made a bowl I could see you being good
at Barn bro I actually won are you good
at bowling no I'm not oh I mean I mean I
hit a couple strikes but what's the
highest I ever got was like 140 150 I'm
like yo that's way higher than I ever
got dude I scored like a 118 the other
day and I thought I was the man I
thought I was the man too I was a kid
when I did 150 Euro the other day I got
70.
yeah yeah 70 dude I so I try to avoid
the double digits because I feel like
that oh yeah I would love to avoid
double digits well I I don't either I
hit like a 87 the other day and I was
playing with my friends
um so yeah I don't avoid them either but
I feel like there's not much in the
midwest to do bowling do bowling yeah
yeah so so bowling the drugs the pizza
the museums don't forget oh yeah the
museums
the wind yeah what more do you need what
more do you need chapped lips nothing
else how about hold on one of our notes
here oh Marty I like that hold on live
Goblin in Chicago I'm seeing I'm good
you want this sure so
I've been seeing you tweet a lot about
stand-up comments so um I kind of want
to give stand up a go
um a lot of people like people have been
telling me to do it for a long time and
I've always been interested in it you
know I've never done anything like that
before but I just think it would be kind
of fun you know whether I flop or not I
don't think I will you know I think I'd
be I think it'd be fun you know I want
to try it so I was thinking I was like
well I don't really want to just go to
some open mic night you know and just
like talk to a bunch of random people I
was like I could make it an event you
know
um have your first time ever be a fuller
yeah bro like I was sitting there and I
was like all I gotta do is rent an event
space get some security oh yeah by the
way I talked to him last night hell yeah
yeah hell yeah after this yeah beautiful
that space easy
so you're not just thinking about it
you're playing yeah yeah I'm looking
into it for sure I'm uh I definitely
like do you have a bit like do you have
an hour I haven't thought about any of
that [__] oh okay I'm just sitting here
I'll probably get to it you know but I'm
just I wanna
um I wanna look into the event space see
how much it costs I mean realistically
how long is it gonna take me to get a
little bit together you know I mean not
that long I also feel like a lot of [__]
that you know I can say and talk about I
don't know I don't necessarily need to
write a ton of stuff yeah oh I feel you
you're good at just free form speaking
Yeah just talking yeah yeah I think I
appreciate that live stream yeah pretty
much it's just a stream bro because it's
different you're not out there like Oh
I'm a community I need to be respected
by communities by comedian to suck my
[__] dick I don't care dude [__]
these people here for myself so we're
starting our live podcasting this year
and I told Mario like I want to start it
out with like me like you guys should
come 10 minutes no I'm saying like
stand-up [__] because I've been writing
yes forever yes I uh
I almost I won't this guy that does a
lot of comedy comedy central specials uh
I wrote out like 15 minutes I did it for
him he gave me some notes that was the
first time I ever did any of that it was
like right before the pandemic happened
because it's something I always want to
do I'm like I think I could do it and if
it sucks yeah I don't give a [__] I
think it'd be fun yeah so what you say
I'm like yeah it'd be fun right yeah yes
I don't want to do a bunch of strangers
what if we threw out and that's when
we're like What if we just did at the
beginning of our [__] show like
starting with like you should 10 minutes
you should bro smoking a joint you
should I I feel like I don't know dude
you should you should like come perform
at the event like we should collab on
the event I see what you're saying you
already have bits I like this yeah for
damn sure let's do it
if you're on a stage with a mic in your
hand you're allowed to say you can say
anything like honest to God I'm not
saying I would say it but I probably
could say the n-word if I was on stage
with a mic you know so realistically I
mean I don't know if you get the Full
Pass
Bros
good enough I think I will stop it
you're completely you know you're
completely right if your [__] was
[__] funny enough yeah and they're
like at the end like okay without you
saying that not as funny yes also you're
running the risk of course and I think
after I say I'm just gonna go do this
life's a risk Life's a gamble what are
you gonna do go to Brown I can say stuff
yeah I can't do that
um see I can't do that I can't I'm
really white I'm super super awesome
the bottom like that yeah upper arm okay
I'm gonna pass a little right yeah I got
wider the further up my arm oh yeah I
mean look at how Caucasian
um stand up would be great yeah oh the
night you know how Wild this is what I'm
talking about school the night I went to
go do that [__] for that stand-up dude
uh we're at some bar went outside talked
to the thing I went in and it was closed
down but he knows the bar guy so he let
us sit at the bar it was closed down
because they had a private party and I'm
looking over him this is in Hollywood
I'm looking over at the table just
randomly and I'm like
is that my teacher from seventh grade oh
no way the guy that made me want to get
straight A's that's the reason why I
started what a beast I had Straight A's
and he says if you do every assignment I
will automatically bump you up a full
letter grade what a beast and that's why
I got for puno because I had a B plus
and he bumped me up a plus because I did
all my work right Mr Mondo he's the dude
that I had math student of the year
because of him he's the one the guy gave
me the award and um
that's why I'm so good with packs anyway
I was doing this thing we're talking I
look over I'm like are you you kidding
me it's happened to be his birthday and
the owner of the Red the bar happened to
be his friend and I talked to him for
like 10 minutes it was the craziest [__]
I hadn't seen him in Forever
and he's like what are you doing I'm
like I'm just with this guy and then I
kind of told him he's like what the [__]
oh that's great he was stoked he's like
what the [__] that's what you're doing
here I thought you were just hanging I'm
like no I live here it was just such a
weird like full circle like the guy that
made me want to try how Mr Mondo shout
out to you from Tanaya yeah that's
[__] safe yeah it was a trip bro I
only ever had like one teacher I liked
like that that actually cared I wrote
her a nice email one day but yeah
recently a couple years ago really years
ago when you did it uh oh hell yeah I
was wasted I was like you know I should
ride
so I was I was drunk and I was also
coked up and it was like it was like 6
a.m bro I was geeked did she respond oh
yeah bro she actually was trying to she
was like oh she said nice to hear from
you no I'm just kidding no it wasn't
delicious
class in high school wasn't like that um
she wasn't my favorite because of you
know her looks I'll say that she looked
kind of like uh oh now you're gonna
compare it I don't know she just Mrs
Puff she was a great woman I'll say that
she was just she had a good heart uh oh
so I like the way you
[Music]
she had a good heart yeah
you realize you're about to be addicted
yeah no no but
um so yeah either way I wrote her I was
super geeked up all morning I just wrote
her a nice email I was like oh thank you
for being so kind because she she was
like super cool I was flunking her [__]
bro I I was getting a terrible ass grade
but it was because I didn't do any
homework and the homework was the
majority of her class so I was passing
my tests but we don't get graded for
anything but homework and tests and more
of the grade was homework fantastic plus
it you can't get a c with the whole I
got a 30 ah see our teacher because I
also so to be fair I didn't show up for
finals so what the [__]
by the time I was already by the time
finals time came
um it was over it was like I had like a
50 something percent you weren't making
it so it was like bro I would have to
like Ace this final yeah I get it
so I took the class twice and the
teacher was super cool
um she was like super nice about it she
was very encouraging like she was always
like oh like you know don't give up on
the class like I know you can do it you
just don't want to you know which is
true
um she was super cool about it but also
it was my geometry teacher and I I still
don't know geometry
that [__] is oh my [__] your shapes I
know like this I I whenever I talk about
this there's always so many people that
that comment on my [__] they're like
damn you don't even know geometry [__]
no it's like bro when am I ever gonna
use geometry dude
what I'm trying to hang [__] I'm like
the angle of this would work we're
building our Channel if I knew geometry
I guess I could put this table together
just higher and I just hired Trent yeah
you know what yeah just [__] this I'm
paying a guy who knows geometry because
I sure as hell don't know that thank you
two times in two different things as
well I wasn't important oh my God should
I hit this up right up right yeah it's
gonna it's gonna be dripping
oh you can see that [__] going
oh yeah I might have rolled too much
weed at the tip you can kind of see the
paper burning around it
yeah we'll be I put it at the very end I
hateful to put it in the middle you
gotta wait 20 [__] minutes to hit it
I hate it I tasted already
um
okay hold on real quick can I ask a
question yeah what do you think about
this raw lawsuit
a lot of it is hoopla a lot of it is
[__] you know uh initially reading
the Articles yeah sure it looked bad but
you also have to remember those articles
are from like no name what the [__]
Outlets like it was just random websites
um
and a lot of the stuff in the lawsuit is
technicalities like it's not really very
bad but there are a couple things in
there that are kind of concerning yes
um I think the location part is [__]
because I had no valid reason to lie
about where they're actually made
um because they're only processed the
papers were only processed in Spain
um not actually made there when they get
like France yeah they're in France which
why even lie like there's no problem I
personally I wouldn't it wouldn't vary
that doesn't decision oh that doesn't
change my decision I wouldn't look at
that be like oh France Francis
yeah France has a good reputation for
things you know like when I think of
French products I think like wine and
cheese I'm like
I'll smoke some French papers you know
but like Spain
I don't even give a [__] about alcoy
dude like whatever they're talking about
yeah like I don't I thought that was
awesome
yeah lied about them like lied really
don't look with that weak part lead with
the other yeah that didn't matter
um they aren't allowed to claim that the
papers are made with natural hemp gum
anymore
but I think that that one was just a
technicality too it's I might be wrong I
don't know I'm not an expert but also
um
I don't know I mean I mean it's the
charity work and it's the metal so the
cheaper that people really care about
actually the paper is [__] yeah the
medals in the paper isn't even real
that's not in any legal document the
medals in the paper is just some random
rumor
um that's not true at all no but
the uh the Charities so there actually
is a you know
verifiable track record of raw giving a
lot of money to charitable you know
things like doing their own drives and
donating to Charities and they've
provided proof of that it's called raw
giving they have proof of their actual
like transactions Josh kesselman is like
come out and like showing them and stuff
um I don't know if he's exactly shown
them but he's like uh posted on the raw
giving Instagram like more proof of the
amounts they've contributed and stuff
and
um they've always been open about what
they do it's it's been a thing for a
long time but it's not a registered
charity it's not a tax-exempt charity
um but they were never collecting
donations or anything they were just
using so by not tax exempt means like
they can't put it on their taxes they
pay taxes on the charity like the
charity is not a tax exempt organization
so which means which means like I
yeah I don't know I so I guess the
reasoning behind it um
at least from what I read is that he
didn't want to not pay taxes you know he
was like he was trying to like do some
honorable thing like oh I'll pay taxes
but like so that's bad
wouldn't that be like a plus like oh
yeah yeah I mean I guess it would be a
plus I like
um but I think so some of the stuff that
I read and I'm not sure if it's correct
or not but some of the stuff that I read
said that they had claimed uh in
interviews that it was a registered
charity when it wasn't which I guess
could have caused the issue gotcha but I
couldn't find any of those interviews so
hmm I don't know it might have been an
interview with like someone at the
company because I was looking for like
interviews with Josh we've discussed it
um and I I couldn't find any so I don't
really know but I think it's a lot of
technicalities and at the end of the day
uh OCB paper still suck dick so
you don't feel differently about raw not
really yeah
that's great it was amazing I have a
video my very first story time of the
year Nick coming out this year is about
raw paper situation
because a lot of the first lawsuit was
about me in the OCB soon raw was about
me so I don't know if it was the same
lawsuit but this is like seven years ago
so OCB tried to recruit my ass and then
when I told him you know I'll wait for
the story but
it's a long story they just couldn't
sound salty yeah I'm not I'm not sitting
here trying to like they're super
corporate and like I'm just saying like
from my perspective me nobody else in
the Earth has this perspective because
OCB didn't try to recruit you [__] so
people like you're just rapping Raleigh
suck my dick so listen to what I'm
saying
like after I told no then they try to
sue Josh about it it's like
what that's like yo girl let me get your
number oh you're ugly anyway that's
exactly what they did basically so we'll
talk more about in the videos but I just
want to get your opinion on it because
what you can look up is what I can look
up yeah I mean so I I've never even been
contacted by any of the rolling paper
companies like they've never hit me up I
have no affiliation with raw any of them
you know you're just talking about uh as
a normal consumer so yeah as a consumer
they can all suck my dick for all I care
but like personally I think uh OCB is
pretty trash and I think the lawsuit was
kind of petty you know
I've seen certain people
um really trash and Raw on social media
which is unfortunate it's good to see
though because now that everybody's like
oh you're lying you're lying and then
three days later like oh it just wasn't
registered but you did give money and
you paid taxes it's good so you can see
all the people are saying colors still
and I'm saying you see a lot of people
how they really feel and that's a that's
a good it's a flush it's like a toxin
flush out of your life you know what I
mean like oh you're a hater
didn't know that
I don't know it's it's good it's good to
relax let news like that sit for a
little bit let it play out then kind of
making like a thousand Diaz like you
need to speak on like no I don't I don't
own that company
I don't yeah yeah I mean I've had a
bunch of people tell me I should like
make a video on it I don't really care
that much you know thank you and then
what happens like story time you know
what my story time about the lawsuit
there's like it's like a little bit of
it
my story about this raw is like from
2014. yeah you have an actual like all
the crazy [__] I used to run their
Instagram I used to run there but there
was a time me and Josh did not [__] with
each other whatsoever yeah not talking
don't call me don't [__] hit me up I
don't want to talk to you right now and
I know a lot of people like whoa that's
happened I mean it happens in business
and she'll work it's like yo is this
just not working and you're pissing me
off yeah so I have a long history with
this Josh Josh is the man he's been on
the show that's him on and off camera
that's how he is so I remember when he
came into the studio though he was like
a little bit like acting like he didn't
know if you were going to be super happy
or not
oh I don't know really yeah
me and him we chilled because this is a
long time ago meeting where butt hurt
each other
like I quit [__] with raw for a while
like I didn't ever talk about it because
I'm not a gossip [__] but like at the
time I didn't just go hey by the way
[__] no there's let it be like I don't
care
but it's been like eight years so you
know let's talk damn let's talk about it
it's a long story and they're supposed
to be making push cheese papers for me
and all this [__] so
that's why I brought I was like you know
what [__] it let's talk about it because
people yeah might as well might as well
at this point but you know what I'm
saying like you're not a contracted by
that
it's it's gone
it's going I can see it started a drip
right here oh my God the rosny you could
definitely takes the differences
[Music]
all type of flavors are hitting right I
got a question so if we were to pull
right now uh your YouTube your Spotify
your Netflix your all your evenings
Spotify yet okay any of you things that
you listen to throughout the day Oh you
mean that I listen to I thought you
meant like platforms I'm on I was like
yeah yeah no this is a viewer what's
your most viewed this year the past
couple months stuff that you're watching
[Music]
um
or listening to music YouTube TV so
music wise I've started listening to
lucky I didn't listen to him before he's
from Living Legends
no l-u-c-k-i
oh oh never mind uh I was like wow
no no I haven't been lucky I am never
mind I know there's another rapper named
Lucky there is six um I started
listening to him uh I I didn't like his
older stuff but I think his newer
stuff's really good uh he did a song
with future that I liked yeah I probably
heard um yeah probably at some point but
I don't really like listen to that much
music except for when I'm like not home
and smoke weed or I'm out doing
something where I'm not listening to
music myself you know so I don't listen
to music that much but um
in terms of Netflix I rewatched The
Sopranos recently it's a good show so
good it's great so good watch He's bound
and down no
there's something you're gonna love
Kenny Powers Kenny Powers you need to go
watch Eastbound and Down okay it's only
four seasons you're gonna love it it's
Danny McBride you know that is yes I
love short and sweet Danny McBride you
ever seen Vice principals no ever seen
the Magnificent gemstones no okay it's
all Danny McBride
shows I know who Danny McBride is though
eastbound down is about a baseball
player that used to be on the top and
then now he is a normal life guy but
it's played by Danny McBride and he's an
entitled [__] but it's the funniest
show I think one of the funniest scenes
in TV history is when you know I won't
even break you got to watch it all right
it's one of my favorite shows it's my
fifth favorite show of all time I will I
will uh go favorite shows ever top three
all right Sopranos instantly immediately
um
comedies too it could be the Simpsons
it's a little tough after that so OG
Simpsons I would say that 15 and down
but it's just been on a downward spiral
for a long time uh to be fair most of
those old shows have you know
um all right this is an OG one this is
like a childhood show for me but I I
feel like I have to rank it highly go
Dexter's Laboratory oh Dexter's Lab was
great that [__] was late was sick I
don't know if it's number two but it's
like in the you know
remember the episode where Dexter wanted
to learn everything in the world and his
brain got real big he met the master and
it was Dede yep yeah
it's like a nightmare I remember that I
was like no I was such a Dexter fan is
fantastic that's a good show number
three so I have um there's this one show
that I used to watch a lot of honorable
mention breaking bad but I don't want to
be like you know basic [__] and
be like yeah breaking bad but it's
probably one of the best shows of all
time it is though yes it's definitely
yes I I love it don't get me wrong but I
didn't like how it ended I loved I
didn't I didn't I love my yo you
deserved it bro I thought early on it
was really interesting but it kind of
just turned into like
let's cook Jesse for like three seasons
that's true
and then Walter would like you gotta
respect the man's wrong Jesse would like
meet someone and then Walter would kill
them and then like Jesse meet someone
Walter kills him you know like just
keeps happening I get it
so I don't know
so I don't know so what's another show
oh
I'm [__] cooked holy [__] all right
number three flowing number three I
would have to say for number three
by Seinfeld
let's go Seinfeld is very good
I felt very chill why why is soprano so
great
Marty bro
it's like
it's a really so I like you know Mafia
and like mob movies I find them
interesting I like the
um
I don't know I like the action in them I
think they're interesting movies
um it's [__] that doesn't really happen
anymore like that at least you know you
don't have them riding around shooting
tommy guns and [__] but uh I mean I
guess they weren't doing that in
Sopranos either but uh you know what I
mean they were like doing [__] that
Italia isn't really happening that much
now
um
it was just like so well acted James
Gandolfini uh I think was his name uh
R.I.P to that dude he he was just so
good on the show Tony was playing yeah
he was like it felt super real bro
um the guy's that smile when they smile
are scarier those kind of actors the
side characters were all like really
good in their own ways like it was just
crazy it was a show it was a solid show
everyone really killed it and like
everyone who who played a consistent
character on that show was like really
good you know so did you ever watch
Sonic versus Anarchy I've seen some
episodes of it but I never like got into
that I am not compared you know what
show I was just asking don't [__]
think I was comparing these damn shows
sorry for people I I know you're not
comparing no
it's a good show but no they mentioned
Merced in there because they're like the
last place you can get a legal takes
place out there right yeah Lodi I didn't
want to say key words on YouTube at this
point dude it's been crazy lately hasn't
it on YouTube we were talking about
before you got here it's so bad right
now like they cranked it up for 2023
yeah the biggest news ever right Susan I
don't know anything about the new person
coming no she goes the rumor is the new
guy is responsible for nft integration
and development at YouTube
um so he wants nfts and like digital
stuff he's a big like crypto guy
um which will let me smoke weed on the
internet I don't know he only questions
listen crypto Bros are usually either
like total losers or drug addicts I hope
he's smart yeah
right now
right now because if he's not we're all
[__] so could you imagine we see this
fool at a party
could you [__] imagine dragons
at a bar or something [__] I will give
him a zip a day for the rest of his life
if he just lets me be that thing is
hitting like no other it's it's actually
one of the better Donuts are smoked it's
ripping
melting underneath the table I'm dumb
right now
oh we gotta get high with the guy
YouTube [__] I had a question I forgot
oh top three oh top shows okay good [__]
Seinfeld all right so I think it's
office or seinfelds and everyone or
number two oh office is five this has
more characters office is so illegal I
mean so it's like there's more
characters I love office at Seinfeld at
the same time so much is how can I
really pick
but I think I might just go Seinfeld
Seinfeld is Elite in the office it's
unfortunate that Kramer's racist but I
know but it's okay just separate
separate it yeah separate the art from
the artist and then I started thinking
Seinfeld I love it there's only like
four ethnic fools on the show throughout
the whole night
[Music]
that makes you wonder yeah I never
thought about that that makes you wonder
oh I think about it all the time because
I love the show yeah everyone's White
everyone is which is fine but it's more
like totally okay in New York City The
Melting Pot of races
yeah I mean I don't think it really
matters what race anyone is on a show no
but now they're thinking about like
and you'll have to remember this movie
you gotta go out here this show you have
to remember this show is like 20 30
years old it's the best show ever so oh
it's amazing yeah it does not change my
opinion at all I watch it so much that I
know what episode's like yeah the
Mexican dude all the black guy oh the
black lady the white dude like every
episode but it's fine I don't give a
[__] they're funny
does not sway my opinion but I'm just
saying damn uh office Seinfeld Always
Sunny in Philadelphia you watch that uh
I've watched some episodes also I
haven't like really binged it it might
be one of the best a lot of my friends
tell me to watch that it's just too good
I've heard it's good it's so funny bro
it's just it's just so it's it's really
like that it's so [__] you've got to
be like the 10th person to tell me this
like I have every seasonal DVD I mean
I've watched a couple of episodes I
didn't really get into it I didn't think
it was bad or anything it just didn't
like that you have it once in the end
you gotta I tried watching the new Lord
of the Rings show that Amazon did
because Loki I used to read the books a
show about it now yeah bro well the
movie slapped well you don't like Lord
of the Rings so long and boring draw the
ring dude I hate him dude
I really wish I could get it but I'm
more like
Lord of the Rings is fire dude the world
is crazy I remember being a kid and
reading that book and I couldn't believe
it but they get final dragons there was
you could fly in that in that movie uh
was there fun and stuff yeah they have
that [__] why they fly on them and just
drop them
they're not like rich and like you know
well off like that this dude's like bro
like they got The Hobbit in that hoe
like he doesn't have [__] bro he's like
two feet tall he lived in a hole in a
mountain or a hole in a hill yeah you
know just like a little dirt you're not
wrong but hey he's not a warrior
you know he had Gandalf like helping him
out sometimes but like you mean Raiden
I mean dude he did he just didn't they
didn't have the resources and people
were gonna hate me now because I hate
Lord of the Rings I don't give a [__]
okay
dude they're cool yeah I'm just not
gonna watch him again oh you know what I
should because I haven't watched them
since they came out you should watch
them dude Harry Potter
I don't know which one's which Star Wars
same [__] I don't know why like if no
one's making me laugh like I agree with
you on Star Wars
I know that I liked him when I was a kid
I don't really care for Star Wars but I
love the uh the games
bro the Lego ones have you played those
the the Lego Star Wars
dude oh hold on hold on
then Kirby enthusiasm have you ever
watched that
no but I know what it is I know it is
that's my fourth favorite show and
number five is Eastbound and Down
I used to really like Workaholics
Workaholics I've only seen the whole
episodes of it surprisingly it's funny
I've never finished it but the ones I
watched were funny I just never came
around because if I watched them I want
to watch every I also think South Park
is on point sometimes for cartoons it's
probably the number one or two not ever
a show that I've watched like
consistently like every episode I've
watched most episodes you know because
when I was a kid I used to just I
thought the cuss words were the greatest
you know like I remember when it came
out right well I remember the first one
I watched was Barbra Streisand Megan
Streisand and Tom's Rhinoplasty and we
were in Mariposa with my stepdad the
same one he almost got eaten by a jaguar
or a mountain lion same exact place
and they were in fourth grade so I
thought it was like the coolest [__]
yeah I mean like he's cussing he's like
I'm not fat I'm like yo me neither man
dude after the earlier episodes were
still funny as hell but it's like well
progressively worse I mean funny like
the kids got the episodes got the
content was so much more [__] up not
worse like
they they didn't need to have a filter
back then and they do now
no no I think it's the opposite they
said less when when they were young like
in the earlier years now they're saying
I mean the f word the eights episodes
there's a lot of episodes I can point
out like whoa they got away with that
because you're a cartoon how funny
I just think horrible shit's funny
I disagree I think the old episodes were
way more offensive bro really yeah dude
give me like season one two three first
five or six seasons compared to like the
new shade of South Park probably way
more offensive honestly really
a hundred percent
they did not give a [__] back then bro
which season do you say it one through
five I'd say like they were sir timid
and that's like no I disagree dude I
disagree
um which season is where they're just
throwing up every time every time uh
Wendy talks to Stan those seasons that
was a banger episode yeah around them
but like it was like I don't know bro
you have to remember too like back then
Tolkien was just like a normal like big
like consistent joke on the show like
they don't even joke about him anymore
like they don't they don't ever bring up
when's the last time you saw an episode
where token was a joke
I think they beat it to death already
maybe that's why maybe but it's still
hard now like with
when they're making fun of uh come on
what's the guy's name or the lady's name
the Kardashians dad
Bruce Caitlyn Jones cheddar Caitlyn
Jenner yeah when they make fun of her on
the show it is brutal yeah it's almost
like yo this got approved hilarious oh
because I always think of like the
celebrities have to see this this is so
mean yeah oh my dude
but like I still like
I don't know bro
I don't think it's as offensive because
also like Caitlyn Jenner is um I mean
she's done a lot of controversial [__]
to make people dislike her not because
she is like transsexual or anything
um but because she did a bunch of
political [__] on social media that was
not very well liked or supported so I
think that might be why they're making
fun of her because her general public
perception right now is like not amazing
so it's like I learned about things
through South Park people probably
aren't that offended by it you know
that's that's probably much more time
tame they're like oh we'll just make fun
of someone who everyone already hates
you know gotcha instead of like back
then they would just make fun of a whole
category of people oh yeah you know okay
I see what you're saying now when you're
saying how it was more offensive back
then yeah I get what you're saying in
those terms but I'm just saying I feel
like that do you watch South Park not
this intense I can't break down season
by season there it's
Middle School I was listening to Lil
Wayne
early early Drake
before anybody Park
you jerked Drake yeah it was an episode
for last episode it was some [__] how
how early did you know
2007 eight
it's because he was in three miles in
Buffalo yeah oh this one's hit I just
got Scooby Snack oh no
I don't want that careful I always put
my tongue like halfway through my mouth
while I'm smoking in case I catch that
oh I kind of kind of like like a guard
yeah dude what are we talking about is
the is the gobcast still coming yes I've
been working on it it's uh so my
apartment I can't really like fit a
studio in there so I need to get in
office but nowhere wants to rent for me
for less than a year no one wants to get
used to me
um for anything less than a year so I'd
have to break my lease which just sucks
I'm moving out here soon anyways uh so
once we get the fumo warehouse I'm
putting the studio in there so it
doesn't matter when I move out here
because I still come out here all the
time you know
um realistically I could film whatever I
need to for like the four or five days
I'm out here and skedaddle you know
um so we're hoping to launch it soon but
it's in the works good in the works
um I have a guy in Illinois who's local
who can produce it for me but I don't
know if I'm gonna do anything in
Illinois you know it's kind of uh are we
tell you move out here that you finally
getting such a it's so dope to hear like
you're actually
everything you're gonna do is gonna do
this
especially now that you don't do hard
drugs anymore because out here is the
place to do hard drugs and you're coming
to La as a sober person what are the
drugs no but you're saying like you're
back home doing hard drugs
so what you're implying is I'm coming
ready to go oh you're coming sober and
ready to crush it tell me I'm [__]
I'm [__] with you what you're saying
it's super scared of shitless of Scooby
Snacks right now do this
put your tongue up while you smoke it
stops all of them
and I haven't got any
no not your lips your dog so you can
just wait I'm scared I I close my list
well I got it smoked did I not
what the [__] was that do the signal do
the joint where you don't have to hit it
what did you just do like let me see you
never did this what
what look
ready
if you don't want to hit someone's joint
you go like this cover the bottom
what the f uck that works it works well
like this
do we these figures yeah close it
put the hand on the bottom oh and then
hit it
I'll do one finger down just give me a
little more
a little more space in my knees
I got smoke I think I don't know why
you're not getting it so well oh like
this
this is just covering this hole
no you're on the bottom like on your on
your knuckles
oh just covering like here yeah but yeah
it's just to cover that this space
see
yeah yeah there you go yeah I can see
the Cherry light up and everything oh my
God you're gonna make a tutorial on this
one I mean it looks so well especially
have a little joint and you're with
hello homies it's so much easier yeah
try that [__] it works yeah right here
Marty oh God don't get me trying to shut
up yeah you got it I bet you got it
better than everybody like right back
here though between these part not the
front this this part in the back all
right close your hand put this hand like
cupping it
like this and then
look at that cherry bird oh my God
it's like a little box yeah it does rip
like a drive almost like a yeah like a
bubbler exactly
never wear a [__] name
I'm kind of scared of it bro I made it
yeah
I'm not driving yeah wait am I driving
no I'll drive don't worry I'll drive
your car no it's not gonna work oh
that's what I was gonna say earlier the
first time you came here you said
something I went dude no you can't do
that right so actually the other day
when I got here I reversed into some it
was like some Beamer or some Mercedes I
was like [__] that I'm like did you wait
you go no I left like dude you can't do
that one day you're gonna get a sick car
and someone's gonna do that to you it
did happen to me that's why it didn't
happen to me yeah I saw it you just got
the rest you just got the new car yeah
it's been wrapped for a couple months
someone hit me at a bar
um it's not enough to file an insurance
claim no but just looking at it's like
yeah what kind of [__] this is
so I'm dropping it off to get fixed uh
when I get back it's not gonna cost me
that much no it's just one little piece
it didn't even damage the paint below it
just the wrap I want to know how that
happened how do they touch you just
enough to scrape paint but not touch the
body so the white paint that's there is
actually there is like yeah there's a
lot of it bro like if you go up close
and look it's like chunky and [__]
the fact that your car didn't debt is
crazy to me yeah when I saw the first
thing I thought was oh man it's for the
time that you talked about on the show
it has to be from that time it is it's
karma things always come back should
happen always should happen yeah that
sucks man yeah it really does suck but
the last time you were here you said I'm
about to go drop my car off of the rap
right when I get home yeah and now when
you're like oh oh I'm so I'm so blown
about it getting hit but you know it
could have been a lot worse and of
course the easiest thing you could fix
is just yeah was the rapid nightmare
going on like you have to keep taking it
back for bubbles and [__] oh it's
perfect nice oh my guy wrapped it
um and I've I've never had to take it
back I've never needed any extra work I
paid three grand for it
um all said and done I think I paid a
good price yeah
um and he he [__] killed it bro he
wrote Goblin on my fenders I saw it like
I didn't even ask for that it's little I
didn't yeah I didn't ask for it he was
he put it in he's like you think this is
cool could you imagine if you're like no
I was like bro that's sick as [__] dude
I'm scared of this I'll hit it yeah you
know what you yeah I got you yo I'm
[__] extremely hiding yeah I'm super
faded
uh my car gets sold tomorrow I think
the blue one's gone finally you have the
Maybach no I'm supposed to be here this
week these [__] oh I'm still waiting
dude I'm not gonna say anything
but
it's your car you should say something
December 2nd he's like it got here to
the port it's in Long Beach sitting and
I go okay
can I come here he goes no we'll have to
get it released and go oh he's always
from another country at the release they
go cool
January 2nd came right before the Ted
talk I'm like I don't care about the car
I'm studying TED Talk
and I was like January 15th I'm like
where's the car and you're sorry you
know it's at the Port it takes a long
time they the guy has like 12 Lambos
that he ordered for his store and he's
like I'm waiting on this I'm like oh God
you're waiting just okay your worst is
worse than mine he's way worse than mine
I just want to drive it you're trying to
sell and get your money back that sucks
February 2nd I'm like it's been two
months
what's going on here guys
the guy John calls his guide the other
day and he goes hey what's up he goes oh
so it's about to get to the port and go
what did you just say yeah it's supposed
to be San Francisco
you told me it landed in Long Beach
already he was lying [__] oh my
I'm getting that sticker that's why
they're like I think they're trying to
drag it on to see if I just back out of
it so they can go sell it for hella more
because I'm getting in that sticker and
I'm not supposed to it's just because
it's friend so do you think
I think it's there I think it's there
and I think they're [__] with me I
gotta be honest what do you what are you
gonna do you see it then my bad what are
you gonna do if they're actually [__]
with you though like you should sue them
I guess so I haven't been down payment
you should just Rob the dealership
bro mascot I'll go with you bro mask up
man this pool's ready to go he's trying
to get cars yeah Instagram names he was
ready to shoot for some [__] I want
what's he gonna do for the car let a
little Instagram man we'll chop it up
we'll sell it on the internet okay
Marketplace I want the car we'll scam
somewhere it's worth way more in pieces
we'll chop it up
no the car will you know rip the doors
off sell the doors on on Facebook
Marketplace you know
yeah he really is Bubba big he's
slipping into the character
so yeah that's what's going on man
and Rosie's car got hit rear-ended some
guy rear ended she's fine but we're
still waiting on her car so right now
we're about to be carless bro so crazy
no wit that's some real Rich Man Poor
Man [__] on your Maybach that's why I've
been saving my Kia I haven't sold it yet
because I'll get around that old little
beater just for when like well I moved
and it's you'll see I don't want to have
a car always in front of my [__] no my
third party never never you'll see yeah
but uh yeah so it's about to be carless
in my my house right now it's so weird
yeah yeah I'm just waiting that's crazy
are you getting uh like a rental for
while your car's getting fixed or no
yeah if this takes forever dude well
Rosie has her rental but they've had
Rosie's truck forever yeah it's been
like a month yeah they said it should be
done this week oh
well hope I hope oh no I'm thinking yeah
windshield oh yeah because the
windshield waited for four months it was
about to be here like three days and the
guy rare editor so now I still have one
it was brand new they didn't have
windshields yet yeah it's so [__]
and that's some [__] like your car's
new no windshields yet
you should be prepared yeah what how
how'd they make the car then
what do you mean thank you you got
windshields thank you thank you they
have to be around dude how'd you make
the [__] win thank you like there's
no way they don't have windshields they
must exam it's glass someone is able to
make them someone is able to give us
check marks someone was able to stop
deleting us all of these things are a
button a setting on the iPhone I know it
preach man and one says Goblin [__] off
Thomas [__] off preach it's for real
that's how I feel lately but you know
what it's okay because what are we doing
today we're at work essentially
and this is fun we got myself a donut at
work and we're about to oh we're about
to do it real high because you're going
to my house yeah yeah
I'm excited I have I'm ready so much
hash it's it's unbearable I mean almost
unbearable
yes there's so much hash at the house
take the rest yeah there's so much cash
in the house dude wow just not saying
like damn I got people been getting like
yo check out this gram check out but uh
yeah because I moved and I collect you
know I unwrapped everything what the
[__] so I've been giving all my homes
like yo take a jar make a jar take a jar
Never Gonna smoke all of it I will but
not before it starts oxidizing and
turning a little dark and then it's not
great anymore yeah you know so I figured
let's just spread it around so I have
some hash for you too I've been giving
everybody a little jar I was like I
should have brought some today I [__]
up [__]
but anyway besides that Let's get high
as hell I'm just I just woke up I don't
know what happened I was so high a
minute ago I'm still faded I feel like
it's a big win what just happened this
is our first time really that we're
missing the premiere oh yeah
next week after this we got a little
Russell coming on yep excited for that
followed by nle Choppa yep Chopper
coming on so it's about to be a big run
it's gonna be fun and Ali Chapa that's
gonna be interesting we had to get uh
the early Goblin episode because
everybody keeps yo you have no idea what
people ask for the next one of your
episodes in the [__] chat of your
episodes
they asked me on dude every day I tell
them I bring up la
they're like that means the yellow
episodes drop I don't even say I'm going
to La I'll just say the word La I'll
just be like you know oh like I might go
to LA in the future and they're like
you'll episode when yeah no I feel I get
it but it's more like
bro chill yeah people like spam it you
don't live here like they know that that
you don't live here yeah people ask me
every day yes every [__] and even
even if I did I'm not like a host of
this podcast yeah
I'll be there every week we just do five
episodes in a row that are just me like
I'm the guest oh my God Andy Richter
let's get him a little chair like on
Conan and he just comes in and says I
I've done that I've done that drug
before it's just back he's just oh [__]
that's not even a horrible idea yeah
actually I would be kind of chill that's
actually kind of kind of cool
yeah we could definitely do stuff like
that we could totally that would be
interesting
um so real quick you get deleted off
Tick Tock like I get deleted on
Instagram bro I've been deleted like
five times what is your Tick Tock right
now God talk oh okay just in case that's
gone
can people go to your YouTube and click
like your link for tickets yes yes I
have links for all my socials what is
your YouTube channel for everyone it's
just Goblin g-o-b-l-i-n yup go on
YouTube Type in Goblin on the first
result or
it's youtube.com the gbln okay so if you
see your ins your YouTube go you know
where it says videos Community playlist
click the one that says about I have to
explain this I do it all the time click
about and it'll show every link to all
his socials so your Twitter your
Instagram because your Instagram is the
gbln right now also right now yes okay I
tag you all the time and I'm like wait I
get banned all the time yeah and there's
fakes everywhere and I'm not sure they
do a good job yeah because you can't
click them and then look at the profile
while you're tagging fools yeah I know
I'll be tagging the road you're gonna
redo it gotta redo it yeah so Twitter
you go hard as hell you still post on
Twitter a lot what's your Twitter the
goblin one of my favorite Twitter see
with three ends dude listen I get it I
get it it sucks but it's like that's why
I want to save it on everything yeah I
want to say it out loud on everything so
your Twitch
GB on 420. oh my God see it's just like
me I'm like oh no that's underscore
underscore not DOT you're streaming like
three times a week right more than that
no more than that I've been streaming
like almost every day I can't wait till
we go you show me what I'm doing bro oh
I got you because I know there's some
buttons
I [__] got you don't you worry I
stream
um almost every day
um
I stream
not that long like two three hours damn
that's a long time job I go live I make
sure I put in put in my time you know I
think it's fun streaming is fun as hell
talking to people bro
I'm gonna tell you right now the amount
of money that twitch will pay you to run
more ads on your Channel
not more you can even pick the basic
amount the normal amount they're gonna
run and you get an incentive for it
which is three minutes of ads per hour
which is not bad right that's 95 content
right you can also pick six minutes per
hour which is the highest one which is
you know a little up there I think yeah
but on regular TV yeah yeah that's
pretty well no isn't regular TV more I
have no idea I think regular TV is
definitely like every five to eight
minutes is a real commercial yeah but um
get paid more
yes so what you're telling me as he goes
yes I go three
no I am a good person I pick three I I
try not to crank them up but even at
three bro they give you ad incentives
when you start streaming consistently
that are a good amount of money like for
a while I didn't stream that much
this past like month I made it like a
New Year's kind of thing I was like you
know I'm gonna stream a [__] load this
year on Twitch
um so the first month of the year they
offered me like 150 to stream the three
minutes this month they offered me like
700 something just to have the ads on
three minutes yeah wow yeah crazy
crazy that's just an extra bonus every
time you twitch yeah nice yes oh
yeah crazy
it's worth it yeah yeah it makes it
completely worth it yeah crazy [__]
crazy [__] that's why so many people are
like I'm streaming I don't know if I'm
allowed to talk about that actually now
I think about it so maybe we'll bleep
believe the exact amount yeah
I have like 1900 about so nice good
amount so I paid your rent right oh yeah
I pay all my bills with twitch yes but
see that's one stream there's so many
I'm streaming well not one stream no
streams of income stream of income pay
your rent and your bills
see this is why I feel like when people
are out well I don't consistently have
that bro I just got that this past month
and now I can pay my bills
it's just been a crazy ass month
a lot yeah now that stream consistently
I got like a crazy amount of Subs but
before no
but when you make it a job and you
actually put together you put the work
in bro it's it's not it's not and I
think it's a lot more fun to stream on
than YouTube because you can do more
[__] with your chat like you can like
put up polls in in bets and like
interact with people and they have
rewards they can redeem and they can
watch ad free just by being a sub you
know and they get more incentives and
like emotes for being a sub like I don't
know
I think it's I think it's cooler like I
think it's it's more water active it
seems like yeah it's more fun for the
viewer I feel like to stream on um to
like be on Twitch you know I always
watch that like people used to watch
YouTube I can't I can't do it I don't
watch Twitch I can't it's too high it's
too hectic for me it's like making a
Discord yeah I don't know what the [__]
is going on I can't do it reading it for
20 minutes my head hurts I can't do it
dude that's too much but I like doing
like streaming yeah
streaming on Twitch is lit YouTube needs
to like step their [__] up maybe they
will
the craziest thing is I hope he's really
cool because we are saying that on the
platform that we're talking about so
yeah that'd be awesome if you didn't
care that'd be super cool he'll be chill
he'll be chill
I think Neil is Chill
I think so before we leave the studio I
gotta eat you the gummy sharks on the
other side of this wall
the sours I don't know why I looked at
the wall I mean no I got the mangoes
back
those ones you bomb I gotta get you the
new ones they're they're here but um all
right let's do this man that was fun
we just yeah we did isn't that every
podcast no no sometimes so let me bring
up my topic this one I think I looked
this way a few times it got concussed
yeah yeah that was pretty much it wow
that lighter hit really [__] up that's
what this Dent is see this little thing
oh that was gas chicken pox car
what else baby could you imagine if I
played that I was like nah damn awesome
work environment I don't know what I can
do
all right cool so everybody go fall
Goblin on all of his socials I hope that
I hope the tick tock aren't still there
hope you guys got one of them all right
do you have a website goblin420.com and
all my Social Links are at the top
gobble or they'll Goblin goblin420
goblin420.com and that has every social
link that's active yep there so don't
get scammed and my merch is on there
that's just my website your new merch
are you supposed to look sick yeah I got
a crazy designer like it looks at the
front of Goosebumps yeah it's so scary I
uh I hired viewers for my next merch
dropper put out in a video I said email
me some kids sent me the stupidest [__]
I've ever seen
um and then so yeah like one guy
literally dude he took a picture of a uh
like a plug like an outlet like you know
the [__] you plugged into the wall and
just put it on a hoodie like really tiny
like really small like right here
not like you know embroidered or
anything just like that little picture
and it wasn't like cropped out correctly
it was little like specs around it of
like where he didn't crop the picture
right and like edit it
um and he sent me that and he was like
yeah I worked for fifty dollars honestly
I'm just trying to support my Coke habit
bro I hope you hit me back thank you
so I got [__] like that but also I got
hit up by some really talented people
who were definitely uh worth it
definitely worth it yeah definitely
killing it dude I mean the next merch
drop is probably gonna be my best yet so
that's the best that you could say
that's the the level you always want to
say like I don't know how but this one's
better than last yeah bro five years
later the tweet I put out for the last
uh the last shirt has like a thousand
likes already people that sure looks
people are waiting for it if it's the
one with the with the goblin world yeah
yeah I'm sorry it looks like a
Goosebumps border yeah they used to do
like night and Terror Tower or some
crazy [__] I love it yeah it looks
[__] dope uh yeah we're looking for
the next artist right now for post trees
it's Everlast it's ever changing I feel
like fools fall off and they just don't
want to work or I just want to find
somebody I can always depend on for art
yeah like that's where you're at right
now yeah I
hope that I can keep working with these
people because I have so so far I have
three designers that I've hired
I'm not trying to drop like you know a
million different products or anything
but I'm trying to get like two designs
from each so I can drop one from each
this drop and then maybe like save some
for the future
um
and I have like very different styles
but the only thing I told them I never
gave them any instructions for like
ideas I just said make it related to
drugs or my content or goblins like the
creatures you know yeah
um that's it but I figured Sensei
reviewers they would be able to do that
better than if I just got some random
artists and was like yeah of course make
a [__] Goblin related thing because
they're just gonna draw a picture of a
goblin yeah you know like [__] that
um
yeah I think all of them have honestly
killed it like uh one of the guys uh I
tweeted another one today too I don't
know if you saw the one I tweeted
earlier today oh sure um the graffiti
looking one yeah yeah oh you just showed
me it yeah yeah yeah that's the uh so
that's a different designer I hired that
guy to do some [__] and he like draws
his own uh like designs and [__] and
like colors of himself it's just sex so
yeah I'm high for it good [__] so
goblin420.com yes sir for everything
always going to be available there we
ship everything very quick there's one
guy who placed an order for like five
shirts you got his order two days later
good super quick good if UBS USPS or
FedEx does their actual job [__] gets
there on time I'll ship something within
two days and the fools will be yelling
at me like it's been 14 days like yep
how yeah how is this happening there was
only one guy though that's not normal so
see that's I I feel you Dude
no matter what I couldn't believe it
when I saw I was like did he really get
his [__] that early like damn dude it
was the it was definitely the Ross joint
it's got to be slow yeah I'm dumb as
[__] right I can't lie I thought I was
awake I'm not I'm brain dead right now
dude um so thank you so much for being
here I know you're having me brain dead
but we're about to go take a lot of dabs
oh I know we're gonna get stupider yeah
we're gonna take a lot of Dance I'm
ready we're not gonna smoke in the car
whatsoever because there's no Carter of
course there's no car to write that's
okay here
Marty you confuse me
smokey in the car is wrong it's it's
terrible guys thank you so much for
being here uh from Goblin Nick from
Martian sir thank you guys for having me
it's been a blast you have anything else
you wanted that it's fun this is a
legendary way to break in the new set
here feels good yeah I love this set
this [__] is sick huh yeah this is crazy
we'll show you the rest it just looks it
looks cool just
it's different yeah you know what it's
like walking in our warehouse like it's
already boxed yeah it's different it's a
different yeah man it's more
professional it is professional yeah I
like it we're done
and that's it the word belligerent like
let's get food like we still get [__]
up in here yeah oh definitely hot
um all right thanks so much for being
here guys go check out goblin420.com
Marty thank you so much for being here
for everyone driving please be safe
smoke free hang out in traffic please be
careful La is flooded and snowing
be safe out there all right all right
it's snowing out here guys be careful
yeah but not sunny California I can't
believe you guys struggle with it so
hard I don't care it's just wild people
cannot drive I know bro
oh my God I'm from the Central Valley it
rains heavy I don't know what it's like
to try it's just water
when it's real puddled don't hit that
[__] that fast my Uber driver hydroplate
could not hang dude an Uber driver could
not hang well that's because there was
water on his tires yeah there was a
slight amount of water on his slick ass
tires I don't know what it is be safe
out there we're all here talking [__] be
safe out there guys thank you so much
for watching this has been the dope as
usual podcast have a dope ass day
I will never wear a Dandy knee again
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie